I drank tea at Davies's in Russell Street, and about seven came in the great Mr. Samuel Johnson, whom I have so long wished to see. Mr. Davis introduced me to him. As I knew his mortal antipathy of the Scotch, I cried to Davis, don't tell where I come from. However, he said, from Scotland. Mr. Johnson, said I. Indeed, I come from Scotland, but I canna help it. "'Sir,' replied he, "'that I find is what a very great many of your countrymen cannot help.' Mr. Johnson is a man of a most dreadful appearance.
我在罗素街的戴维斯茶馆喝了茶，大约七点钟时，伟大的塞缪尔·约翰逊先生来了，我盼望见他已经很久了。戴维斯先生把我介绍给他。因为我知道他极其痛恨苏格兰人，便对戴维斯喊道，别说我是从哪来的。然而，他还是说，来自苏格兰。我说，约翰逊先生。的确，我来自苏格兰，但我对此毫无办法。他答道，“‘先生，据我所知，这正是你们大批同胞所无可奈何的。’”约翰逊先生的外表看起来十分可怕。
He's a very big man, his troubled with sore eyes, the palsy, and the king's evil. He's very slovenly in his dress, and speaks with the most uncouth voice. Yet his great knowledge and strength of expression command vast respect, and they render him very excellent company. He has great humor and he's a worthy man. But his dogmatical roughness of manners is disagreeable. You don't need AI agents, which may sound weird coming from service now, the leader in AI agents. The truth is, AI agents need you.
他身材高大，饱受眼疾、麻痹症和瘰疬之苦。他的穿着十分邋遢，说话的声音也极为刺耳。然而，他渊博的知识和强烈的表现力赢得了极大的尊重，这使他成为极佳的伴侣。他极具幽默感，是个值得尊敬的人。但他那种教条式的粗鲁举止却令人不快。你不需要人工智能代理，这从作为人工智能代理领导者的ServiceNow口中说出来可能听起来很怪。事实是，人工智能代理需要你。
Sure, they'll process, predict, even get work done autonomously. But they don't dream, read a room, rally a team, and they certainly don't have shower thoughts, pivotal hallway chats or big ideas. People do. And people, when given the best AI platform, they're freed up to do the fulfilling work they want to do. To see how ServiceNow puts AI to work for people, visit servicenow.com. So that is arguably the most famous meeting in British literary history, perhaps all literary history. It took place in Thomas Davis's bookshop off Covent Garden in London on the 16th of May 1763. Now, one of these people was then unknown, but the other one was already a celebrity.
当然，它们会处理、预测，甚至自主完成工作。但它们不会做梦、察言观色、团结团队，它们肯定也没有淋浴时的灵光一现、走廊里的关键闲聊或宏大的想法。人类会。而人类在获得最佳人工智能平台后，便能腾出精力去从事他们想要完成的有意义的工作。想了解ServiceNow如何将人工智能投入实际应用以造福人类，请访问servicenow.com。这可以说是英国文学史上，或许也是整个文学史上最著名的会面。它于1763年5月16日发生在伦敦考芬园附近的托马斯·戴维斯书店里。当时，其中一个人还默默无闻，但另一个人已经是个名人了。
This was the great Mr Samuel Johnson. He was a 53-year-old poet. He was a biographer. He was a critic. He was a great essayist on morals, and he was what's called a lexicographer, which means somebody who basically write down the definition of words and compiled dictionaries.
这就是伟大的塞缪尔·约翰逊先生。他是一位53岁的诗人。他是一位传记作家。他是一位评论家。他是一位伟大的道德随笔作家，而且他被称为词典编纂者，这意味着他基本上就是把词语的定义写下来并编纂词典的人。
And Mr. Samuel Johnson had lived for decades in obscurity and indeed in relative poverty. But in recent years, before this meeting in 1763, he had emerged to become one of the pre-executive. eminent. Well, let's use the word, celebrities of Georgian London, fated across Britain and known indeed across Europe. So Tom, tell us all about Dr. Johnson. So yeah, he is absolutely by this point the dominant literary figure in London. And he is feared as well as admired. So he's been given this nickname, the great cham, which is basically, you know, like the chame is Khan. So like Genghis Khan or
塞缪尔·约翰逊先生曾在默默无闻中度过了几十年，甚至过着相对贫困的生活。但在1763年这次会面之前的几年里，他已经崭露头角，成为了乔治王时代伦敦的最高行政人员。杰出的。好吧，让我们用这个词，名人，他在全英国享有盛誉，甚至在全欧洲也广为人知。那么，汤姆，给我们讲讲约翰逊博士吧。好的，到这个时候，他绝对是伦敦无可争议的文学泰斗。他既令人畏惧又令人钦佩。因此，人们给他起了个绰号，叫“伟大的汗”，这基本上就相当于，你知道的，汗就是可汗。就像成吉思汗或
Kubla Khan, that kind of thing. And it implies an idea that he is an oriental despot of literature. And you get that in the sense of how Boswell describes him, you know, refers to his dogmatical roughness of manners. And Johnson was very capable of aggression in his arguments. But he was also very much loved. He had an incredible genius for friendship. And by this point, he stands at the center of a social circle that included some of the most brilliant and famous men of the age. So that would include David Garrick, the great actor, Joshua Reynolds, famous portrait painter, Edmund Burke, who we've talked about a lot in the context of the French Revolution, one of the most brilliant parliamentarians and orators of his age.
忽必烈汗，诸如此类。这暗含着这样一种观点：他是文学界的东方专制君主。从博斯韦尔对他的描述中，你可以感受到这一点，你知道的，他提到了约翰逊“教条式的粗鲁举止”。约翰逊在争论时非常具有攻击性。但他同时也备受喜爱。他有着令人难以置信的结交朋友的天赋。到了这个时候，他已经成为一个社交圈的核心，这个圈子包括了那个时代一些最才华横溢、最著名的男士。其中包括伟大的演员大卫·加里克，著名的肖像画家约书亚·雷诺兹，以及我们在法国大革命的背景下经常谈到的埃德蒙·伯克——他那个时代最才华横溢的议员和演说家之一。
And all of these people felt like planets revolving around the sun that was Samuel Johnson. And this is because he was above all, perhaps, even more than a great writer, He was one of the supreme talkers of history. And I would guess that in British culture, probably Oscar Wilde is his only rival as the most quoted conversationalist in English. So even now, you know, centuries on from Johnson's time, lots of his comments are still very familiar. So patriotism is the last refuge of a scoundrel. Yeah. When a man is tired of London, he's tired of life.
所有这些人感觉自己就像是围绕着塞缪尔·约翰逊这轮太阳旋转的行星。这是因为他超越了一切，甚至超越了一位伟大的作家，他是历史上最顶尖的谈话家之一。我猜在英国文化中，奥斯卡·王尔德可能是他作为英语世界中被引用最多的对话家唯一的对手。因此，即便在约翰逊生活的几个世纪后，他的许多言论仍然广为人知。比如“爱国主义是恶棍的最后避难所”。是的。“当一个人厌倦了伦敦，他就厌倦了生活。”
The triumph of hope over experience as a description of a second marriage. And to hear Johnson talk, by this point, had become one of the supreme pleasures of London life. He'd basically become an enormous tourist attraction. And there's a problem, obviously, with reports by people that this was a great conversation list before the age of audio recording. Because conversation by definition, as words are spoken, then they fall silent. And so we are told that Cicero was a great conversationalist, or say, Shonigan, the Japanese, writer who we did an episode on last year. But we have no real idea what it was like to listen to these people. We have no real record of Cicero's conversation. But with Johnson, it's different
把“希望战胜经验”用来形容第二段婚姻。而到了这个时候，听约翰逊交谈已经成为伦敦生活至高无上的乐趣之一。他基本上成了一个巨大的旅游景点。显然，由人们的报道来看待这位录音时代之前的伟大谈话家存在一个问题。因为对话按定义来说，当话语说出口后，便归于沉寂。因此，我们被告知西塞罗是一位伟大的对话家，或者像去年我们做过一期节目的日本女作家清少纳言。但我们对于听这些人说话究竟是什么样的并没有真正的概念。我们没有西塞罗对话的真实记录。但约翰逊则不同，
because we can hear him talk more clearly, more completely than any person before him who had ever lived. And so I think that that kind of in and of itself makes him a brilliant topic for a history podcast because it's amazing to hear someone from so long ago the kind of the genuine timbre of what he was saying. But of course, people may be wondering how on earth do we have such detailed records of his conversation? Well, that's down to the man with whom we began the show. So that's his biographer, James Boswell, who at this point was a young man from Scotland. He was only age 22. And he's a pretty remarkable man in his own way, isn't he? Not, I think, remarkable as Johnson, but still a fascinating character.
因为我们能比他之前活过的任何人都更清晰、更完整地听到他说话。所以我觉得，仅凭这一点，他就成为了历史播客的一个绝佳话题，因为能听到这么久以前的人说话的真实音色，了解他说的话，这是一件很神奇的事。当然，人们可能会好奇，我们究竟是怎么拥有如此详细的他的对话记录的呢？好吧，这要归功于我们节目的开场人物。也就是他的传记作家詹姆斯·博斯韦尔，当时他还是个来自苏格兰的年轻人。他年仅22岁。以他自己的方式来看，他也是个相当了不起的人，不是吗？虽说我认为他不如约翰逊那么非凡，但仍然是个迷人的人物。
Well, I think in many ways he is as remarkable as Johnson, it's just that for many, many years, this wasn't apparent. And the way in which it became clear to people that actually Boswell was, you know, was an extraordinary writer and innovator is something that we'll talk about over the course of this series. But just to give a sketch of who Boswell was, I mean, for starters, his accent was probably not as Scottish as you suggested, because otherwise he wouldn't have been able to disguise the fact that he was in fact Scottish.
嗯，我认为在许多方面他都和约翰逊一样了不起，只是在很多很多年里，这一点并不明显。而人们开始意识到博斯韦尔实际上是一个非凡的作家和创新者这一过程，将是我们在这系列节目中要讨论的内容。但为了大致勾勒出博斯韦尔是谁，我的意思是，首先，他的口音可能不像你暗示的那样带有浓厚的苏格兰口音，否则他就无法掩盖他其实是个苏格兰人的事实。
He had been born to privilege, unlike Samuel Johnson, and he was the heir to a long line of lairds in Scotland. And his father was the laird of a place called Affleck. So a bit like Ben, but it's actually, if you read it, you would think it was Orkinlek, which is how I always assumed it was, but I then discovered wasn't. And the laird of Orkinleck, Boswell's father,
与塞缪尔·约翰逊不同，他出生于特权阶层，是苏格兰一脉相承的地主的继承人。他的父亲是一个叫阿弗莱克的地方的地主。所以有点像本，但实际上，如果你读它的话，你会以为它是奥克兰莱克，我一直也是这么认为的，但后来我发现并不是。而奥克兰莱克的地主，博斯韦尔的父亲，
was absolutely from central casting, very stern, very moralistic, very Presbyterian. exactly what you would expect a kind of mid-18th century laird would be like. But Boswell himself, kind of almost as if in reaction to his father, was everything that the laird of Affleck wasn't. He was very gregarious. He was very kind of open-natured. He was absolutely obsessed by sex, particularly at this age. I mean, he just can't stop going on about it. He has a brilliant biographer, John Wayne, who was not the actor, but a poet and biographer. And he kind of perfectly describes Boswell as half ludicrous, half lovable. And part of what makes him
完全就像是照着中央选角模子刻出来的，非常严厉，非常讲究道德，是个坚定的长老会教徒。完全符合你对18世纪中期地主的期望。但博斯韦尔本人，几乎就像是为了和父亲对着干一样，展现出了一切阿弗莱克地主所没有的特质。他非常合群。他的天性非常开朗。他绝对痴迷于性，尤其是在这个年纪。我的意思是，他简直对这个话题滔滔不绝。他有一位出色的传记作家约翰·韦恩——他不是那个演员，而是一位诗人和传记作家。他近乎完美地将博斯韦尔描述为“半是滑稽，半是惹人喜爱”。而让他显得
ludicrous is that he's absolutely obsessed by celebrity. And you kind of havered over whether to describe Johnson as a celebrity. But there is something very contemporary about Boswell's obsession with bagging famous people. You know, he'd absolutely be a person for a selfie today. And he had actually been stalking Johnson for weeks before he finally got to meet him in that bookshop. And the account of it that we began this episode with is from the journal entry that Boswell wrote that evening after he had met Johnson. And it is one of countless number of journal entries because if there was one thing that Boswell adored as much as meeting famous people, it was writing up details of the famous people that he had met. He was absolutely relentless.
滑稽的部分原因在于，他绝对痴迷于名人。你可能还在犹豫要不要把约翰逊描述为名人。但博斯韦尔对追逐名人的痴迷有一种非常现代的特质。你知道的，他今天绝对是个会拍自媒体合影的人。而且在最终在那家书店见到约翰逊之前，他实际上已经跟踪了约翰逊好几个星期。我们本集节目开篇所引用的关于那次会面的记载，就来自于博斯韦尔在见到约翰逊当晚所写的日记。这是无数篇日记中的一篇，因为博斯韦尔如果有什么和喜欢见名人一样狂热的事，那就是把见过的名人的细节写下来。他绝对是坚持不懈的。
He had this completely obsessional sense of industry. And he does meet loads and loads of famous people. But I think his meeting with Johnson was for him one of the great turning points of his life and indeed one of the great turning points in British literature. At first, Boswell is very anxious, isn't he, that Johnson will find out he's Scottish. And Johnson, of course, does find it out. But the bromance, as it were, begins pretty quickly, doesn't it? So just a few weeks after they've met, Johnson says to him,
他有一种完全出于痴迷的勤奋感。他确实见过了许许多多的名人。但我认为，与约翰逊的会面对他来说是他一生的伟大转折点之一，也是英国文学史上的伟大转折点之一。起初，博斯韦尔非常焦虑，担心约翰逊会发现他是苏格兰人，对吧？而约翰逊当然也确实发现了这一点。但是，这段“兄弟情”可以说进展得相当快，不是吗？因此，就在他们见面几周后，约翰逊对他说：
give me your hand, I've taken a liking to you. And from that point on, you know, they are, they're best friends. Well, they're not best friends, but they're definitely very close to each other and their friendship lasts for 21 years until Johnson dies in 1784. And by that time, Boswell has compiled what he describes as a vast treasure of his conversation at different times. And Boswell isn't exaggerating. I mean, he has reams and reams of accounts of what Johnson had said over the course of these two decades. And it enabled him in 1791 to publish one of the great classics of British literature, the life of Samuel Johnson. And I think it is easily the greatest and most influential biography in the English language. And it is a work that brought a man
把你的手给我，我挺喜欢你的。从那时起，你知道的，他们成了，他们成了好朋友。好吧，他们不是最好的朋友，但他们绝对非常亲密，他们的友谊持续了21年，直到约翰逊于1784年去世。到那个时候，博斯韦尔已经汇编了他所描述的大量约翰逊在不同时期的谈话。博斯韦尔并没有夸大其词。我的意思是，他拥有大量关于约翰逊在这二十年间所说的话的记录。这使他在1791年能够出版英国文学的伟大经典之一——《塞缪尔·约翰逊传》。我认为这无疑是英语语言中最伟大、最具影响力的传记。这部作品把一个人
back to life more fully, I think, than anyone had ever been brought back to life before him. and just to lay my cards on the table, it is my personal desert island book. It is incredibly entertaining and it makes you feel like you're watching a fly on the wall documentary to a degree that nothing else quite like it does. It's an absolutely astonishing work. Well, to pursue this idea of the documentary, the thing about Boswell's Life of Johnson is it's not just a portrait of a man, it's a window onto an age. And this age is the 18th century, so Georgian Britain.
比以往任何被复活的人都更完整地带回了人间，我认为。而且坦白说，这是我个人流落荒岛时必读的书。它极其具有娱乐性，而且让你感觉像是在观看一部墙角苍蝇视角的纪录片，达到了其他任何类似作品都无法企及的程度。这是一部绝对令人惊叹的作品。好吧，为了延续纪录片这个想法，关于博斯韦尔的《约翰逊传》，厉害的地方在于它不仅仅是一个人的肖像，它是一扇通往一个时代的窗户。而这个时代就是18世纪，也就是乔治王时代的英国。
and Georgian Britain is a subject that we haven't really done massively on the podcast and actually doesn't really feature. It's a weird thing. It's a weird kind of lacuna, I think. It's a bit of a black hole in the British national imagination, which is odd because it's the 18th century that the Kingdom of Great Britain is created. It's in the 18th century that it becomes the world's greatest industrial pioneer, the world's greatest commercial power, that the British Empire takes its place as a kind of superpower on the world stage. It's in the 18th century that Britain establishes the template for modernity. And actually what Boswell's life of Johnson gives you, it gives you a sense of the kind of the teeming streets of London, the extremes of wealth and
乔治王时代的英国是一个我们在播客中没有过多涉及的主题，实际上它也没有真正占据显著位置。这是一件很奇怪的事情。我认为这是一个奇怪的空白。它像是英国国家想象力中的一个黑洞，这很奇怪，因为正是在18世纪，大不列颠王国成立了。正是在18世纪，它成为了世界上最伟大的工业先驱、世界最大的商业力量，英国帝国在世界舞台上确立了自己作为某种超级大国的地位。正是在18世纪，英国确立了现代性的模板。实际上，博斯韦尔的《约翰逊传》所呈现给你的，是一种伦敦熙熙攘攘的街道感，财富与
poverty, all the habits and hobbies that made George and Britain tick, so everything from tea to wigs to brandy to stagecoaches, all of those kinds of things. It gives us a window onto the politics of the day. Again, something we haven't touched at all really in the rest of history, and something that goes almost unmentioned in popular history in Britain. So this is 18th century wigs and Tories, arguments about slavery, arguments about Jacobitism, about the seven years war, the American Revolution and so on. And actually the American Revolution, I mean, one of the great things about Samuel Johnson is he has very, very sound views on the tax revolt of the 1770s, doesn't he? Yeah. So this is to question.
贫穷的极端，以及构成乔治王时代英国运作的所有习惯和爱好，从茶到假发、白兰地到驿马车，所有这些。它为我们打开了一扇通往当时政治的窗户。同样，这也是我们在历史的其他部分几乎没有真正触及的内容，并且在英国的通俗历史中几乎被忽略。所以这是18世纪的辉格党与托利党、关于奴隶制的争论、关于詹姆斯党起义的争论、关于七年战争、美国革命等等。实际上，关于美国革命，我的意思是，塞缪尔·约翰逊最棒的一点在于，他对1770年代的税收反叛有着非常非常明确的观点，不是吗？是的。所以这是一个问题。
Bozwell in his biography. Johnson is kind of chatting away, he's having a cup of tea, he's in a very amiable mood. And then suddenly he goes berserk. He said, I'm willing to love all mankind except an American. And Boswell puts except an American in italics. And his inflammable corruption bursting into horrid fire, he breathed out threatenings and slaughter, calling them rascals, robbers, pirates. So our American listeners, I hope, will enjoy that. So you've got, yeah, so you've got all of those kind of aspects of 18th century life. And then, of course, you have the friendship between Johnson, who's this kind of occasionally choleric Englishman.
博斯韦尔在他的传记中写道。约翰逊当时在闲聊，喝着茶，心情非常温和。然后突然之间，他暴怒了。他说，除了美国人，我愿意爱所有人。而博斯韦尔把“除了美国人”用斜体字标出。他那易燃的腐败情绪爆发出可怕的怒火，他发出威胁和屠杀的言论，称他们为流氓、强盗、海盗。所以，我希望我们的美国听众会喜欢这一点。所以，是的，你拥有了18世纪生活的所有这些方面。然后，当然，你拥有了约翰逊和这位偶尔暴躁的英国人之间的友谊。
He's the most English Englishman, arguably, who's ever lived. Yeah. And I think, Dominic, that there are elements of Johnson in you. You're not wrong, Tom. I mean, he's a brilliant man, let's be honest. And he's from the Midlands. Exactly so. And then you have Boswell, who is a romantically patriotic Scott.
他可以说是历史上最英国的英国人了。是的。而且多米尼克，我认为你身上也有约翰逊的影子。汤姆，你没说错。我的意思是，老实说，他是个才华横溢的人。而且他是从米德兰兹来的。完全正确。然后你有了博斯韦尔，他是一个浪漫的爱国苏格兰人。
And so the friendship between them offers a brilliant window onto, you know, the, this broader relationship, as you said, is evolving over the course of the 18th century. And that is between the two countries that are now part of a United Kingdom, England and Scotland. So the act of union that had created the United Kingdom of Great Britain had been passed back in 1707. And as you can see from Johnson's slightly performative scotophobia, there are still plenty of people in both kingdoms, England and Scotland, half a century and more on, who aren't
因此，他们之间的友谊为我们提供了一个极好的窗口，让我们得以审视正如你所说的那样，在18世纪的发展过程中不断演变的这种更广泛的关系——也就是现在构成联合王国的两个国家，英格兰和苏格兰之间的关系。因此，促成大不列颠联合王国的《联合法令》早在1707年就已通过。正如你从约翰逊那种带有表演性质的仇视苏格兰情绪中所能看到的，半个多世纪乃至更久之后，两个王国（英格兰和苏格兰）中依然有大量的人，
really happy at finding themselves in this United Kingdom. And I think it's, you know, it's evident from Boswell as well, because when he comes to write up that record in his journals and put it in the biography, he slightly expands on how mortified he'd felt that that opening gamut of his, so his comment, indeed, I come from Scotland, but I cannot help it. He's worried that this might have seemed, as he puts it, a humiliating abasement at the expense of my country. He doesn't, that hadn't been at all what he'd meant. But Johnson's response, that I find is what a very great many of your countrymen cannot help. What Johnson is saying is, yeah, of course, you know, London is absolutely heaving with people who have come from Scotland,
并不是真的很开心发现自己身处这个联合王国之中。而且我认为，这一点从博斯韦尔身上也很明显，因为当他把这段记录写进日记并收录进传记时，他稍微扩展了自己当时感到多么羞愧，因为他那开场的交锋——也就是他的评论：“的确，我来自 Scotland，但对此我无可奈何。”他担心这可能会显得，正如他所说，“以牺牲我的国家为代价的屈辱性卑躬屈膝”。他并非此意，那根本不是他的本意。但约翰逊的回复是：“据我所知，这正是你们大批同胞所无可奈何的。”约翰逊的意思是，是的，当然，你知道的，伦敦到处都是来自苏格兰的人，
i.e. immigrants from Scotland who are cluttering up the streets and taking jobs or whatever. So there's a definite sense of tension there. But, you know, as I say, they have that this great friendship emerges. And I think that it can be seen almost as a man. metaphor for how England and Scotland over the second half of the 18th century start to be reconciled, start to kind of build a common country together. There's a particular moment, isn't there, that symbolises this. And this is one of the most famous moments in the Johnson Boswell friendship. Actually, one of the most famous expeditions of the 18th century, when Boswell, overcoming Johnson's,
也就是说，来自苏格兰的移民拥挤着街道，抢占工作等等。因此，那里有一种明确的紧张感。但是，正如我所说，他们之间建立起了这种伟大的友谊。我认为这几乎可以被视为一种隐喻，象征着英格兰和苏格兰在18世纪下半叶如何开始走向和解，开始共同建立一个国家。有一个特别的时刻，不是吗？它象征着这一点。这是约翰逊与博斯韦尔友谊中最著名的时刻之一。实际上也是18世纪最著名的远征之一，当时博斯韦尔克服了约翰逊的
as you said, slightly performative disdain for Scotland, he persuades. Johnson to come with him to the very wildest, remotest and most Scottish bits of Scotland. Yeah, which are the Hebrides. And so they go on this amazing road trip in 1773, right out into kind of the loneliest, wildest island in the North Atlantic. And it's one of the great adventures of early tourism. And we will be coming to it in due course. Right. Well, before we get to Scotland, let us begin.
正如你所说，那种对苏格兰略带表演性质的轻蔑，他劝说约翰逊和他一起前往苏格兰最蛮荒、最偏远、最具苏格兰风情的地方。是的，也就是赫布里底群岛。于是他们在1773年进行了一场精彩的公路旅行，直奔北大西洋中最孤独、最蛮荒的岛屿。这是早期旅游业的伟大冒险之一，我们随后就会讲到。好啦，在到达苏格兰之前，让我们开始吧。
We'll begin where we ought to begin. where all podcasts should begin and we'll begin in the Midlands. So we're going to begin with, not with Boswell, but with the older man, with Samuel Johnson, the man who reigned like a despot over 18th century literary London. So the thing is, when Boswell meets him, Johnson is a celebrity, but he's 53 years old. And for most of those 53 years, he's been effectively a nobody. Nobody has been writing down what he did. Nobody has cared that he even exists. He has been toiling in obscurity. So take us into Johnson's background.
我们将从应该开始的地方开始，所有播客都应该开始的地方，我们将从米德兰兹开始。所以我们要从博斯韦尔开始，但不是博斯韦尔，而是那位年长的人，塞缪尔·约翰逊，那个在18世纪文学界的伦敦像专制君主一样统治的人。所以问题是，当博斯韦尔遇到他时，约翰逊已经是个名人了，但他已经53岁了。而在那53年的大部分时间里，他实际上是一个无名小卒。没有人记录过他做过什么。没有人关心他是否甚至存在。他一直在默默无闻地劳作。那么，带我们了解一下约翰逊的背景吧。
Well, I mean, the thing that's amazing that he becomes the great cham, this kind of despot ruling literary London, it's not just how long it takes him to reach the status, but the depths of disadvantage from which he emerges. And he has so much going against him. So first, his background, who said that Boswell is the son of a laird, Johnson comes from much humbler origins. So his father, Michael Johnson, is a bookseller, and he lived in Litchfield, which is a very ancient town in the Midlands. So my father briefly lived, actually. And at the time, the Midlands, as you all well know, Dominic, were experiencing kind of explosive growth. Cradle and modernity. And so Birmingham, which is a close neighbour of Litchfield, at this point, is probably the fastest growing city on the face of the planet. You know, industrialisation is starting to kick in. Lots and lots of money is being made. And this might have seemed good news for Michael with his bookshop.
嗯，我的意思是，神奇的是他成为了“伟大的汗”，这个统治文学伦敦的专制君主，不仅在于他达到这种地位花了多长时间，还在于他崛起时所处的劣势深渊。他面临着那么多的不利条件。首先是他的背景，刚才有人说博斯韦尔是一个地主的儿子，而约翰逊则出身于更卑微的家庭。所以他的父亲迈克尔·约翰逊是一名书商，住在利奇菲尔德，这是米德兰兹一个非常古老的城镇。所以我的父亲曾在那里短暂住过。当时，正如你们都很清楚的，多米尼克，米德兰兹正在经历爆炸式的增长。现代性的摇篮。因此，与利奇菲尔德紧密相邻的伯明翰，在当时可能是地球上发展最快的城市。你知道的，工业化开始兴起。大量大笔的财富正在被创造出来。对于开着书店的迈克尔来说，这似乎是个好消息。
But the problem is he's a terrible businessman. He has absolutely no head for figures at all. And so he is constantly teetering on the edge of financial ruin. Johnson's mother, Sarah, she prided herself on coming from a slightly superior family background to that of her husband. And she does have, you know, occasionally, as we will see, legacies come in. There are ways of sourcing money sometimes. But she finds herself being dragged down into the financial bis by her husband. And anyone who's read 18th or 19th century literature, it's a very, very familiar story. The kind of shopkeeper, who wants to maintain respectability, but ends up ultimately ruined. And this is Johnson's background. It's a little bit of the McCorbers about them, I think. Well, yes, except that there's ultimately no saving them, as we will see. So the infant Samuel, he gets, you know, it's not the most propitious kickoff,
但问题是，他是个糟糕的商人。他对数字完全没有概念。因此，他经常处于财务破产的边缘。约翰逊的母亲莎拉，为自己出身于一个比丈夫略微优越的家庭背景而感到骄傲。正如我们将会看到的，她确实有时能得到遗产。有时会有筹集资金的途径。但她发现自己被丈夫拖入了财务泥潭。任何读过18和19世纪文学的人都会发现，这是一个非常非常熟悉的故事。那种想要保持体面但最终破产的店主。这就是约翰逊的背景。我觉得他们身上有点麦考伯一家的影子。嗯，是的，只不过最终没有人能拯救他们，正如我们将会看到的。所以幼年的萨缪尔，他遭遇了，你知道的，这并不是最吉利的开端，
but also he gets a very, very unfortunate start in life for health reasons, doesn't he? Yes. So this is the other factor that makes Johnson, kind of rise to literary fame so extraordinary. He has terrible health all his life. And the reason for this, I mean, it's kind of tragic. His mother is to blame. So she's 40 when she gives birth to Samuel,
但由于健康原因，他在人生的起跑线上也遭遇了一个非常非常不幸的开端，不是吗？是的。所以这就是另一个让约翰逊的文学成名之路如此非凡的因素。他一生都有着糟糕的健康状况。而原因在于，我的意思是，这有点悲惨。他的母亲难辞其咎。她生萨缪尔时已经40岁了，
which is old certainly for the 18th century. And so she's worried about whether she can give Samuel the milk that he will need. And so she looks around for a younger wet nurse and finds one, hands the baby over to this wet nurse. But the tragedy is that unknown to both Johnson's mother and the wet nurse, the wet nurse is tubercular. And after 10 weeks of breastfeeding, Johnson writes later, I was taken home a poor, diseased infant, almost blind. And in fact, he is left effectively blind in one eye and a terribly, terribly near-sighted in the other. And his mother is obviously devastated by this and is willing to try whatever she can to cure him.
这在18世纪当然算高龄了。因此她担心自己是否能给萨缪尔提供所需的乳汁。于是她在周围寻找年轻的奶妈并找到了一个，把婴儿交给了这个奶妈。但悲剧的是，约翰逊的母亲和奶妈都不知道，这个奶妈患有肺结核。经过10周的母乳喂养后，约翰逊后来写道，我被带回家时是一个可怜、患病的婴儿，几乎双目失明。事实上，他确实导致了一只眼睛几乎失明，另一只眼睛也变得非常非常近视。他的母亲对此显然悲痛欲绝，并愿意尝试任何她能想到的方法来治愈他。
And so she goes so far as to take him all the way to London there to be touched by Queen Anne, who was on the throne at the time, friend of the show, for what was called the King's Evil, which is Scrofila. And the Scrofila had infected him as a result of the wet nurse's milk. And there was this idea that the king or queen would touch the person with scrofila and miraculously heal the person. So unfortunately it doesn't work. And in fact, Queen Anne is the last monarch on the British throne.
于是她甚至不远千里带他去伦敦，让当时的在位女王安妮女王——也就是节目的老朋友——触摸他，以治愈所谓的“国王之疾”，也就是淋巴结核。而由于奶妈的乳汁，淋巴结核已经感染了他。当时有一种迷信认为，国王或女王触摸患有淋巴结核的人就能奇迹般地治愈此人。不幸的是，这并没有起作用。事实上，安妮女王是英国王位上最后一位
who does this because, you know, this is an age of rationalism is dawning. I think they should bring that back. I think the king should do it, frankly. Well, it's the way to tell if they're the real king, right? And Johnson, as we will see, is very respectful of the throne. And so he doesn't dismisses out of hand. But he says, basically, he was left, and I quote him, with some confused remembrance of a lady in a black hood, which was Queen Anne. And the queen had given him a little amulet when she touched him, and he always wore this around his neck. The amulet doesn't really make up for the fact that he He's blind in one eye, and he's basically, whenever you meet Dr. Johnson later on, I mean, you will see straight away.
这样做君主的君主，因为，你知道的，理性时代正在曙光初现。我觉得他们应该恢复这个传统。坦白说，我觉得国王应该这么做。嗯，这也是判断他们是否是真国王的方法，对吧？正如我们将会看到的，约翰逊非常尊重王位。所以他并没有直接否定这种做法。但他说，基本上，他留下的记忆是，我引用他的话，“对一个戴着黑色头巾的女士有一些模糊的记忆”，那就是安妮女王。女王在她触摸他时送给他一个小护身符，他一直把这个护身符戴在脖子上。这个护身符并不能弥补这样一个事实：他
Like, he's got his scrofula, he's twitching, he's doing all kinds of stuff. Like, he's a very unprepossessing person, isn't he, physically? Yes. He has violent, convulsive gestures that a lot of people find alarming, I think. That's why I raised an eyebrow when you said there were elements of Dr. Johnson that reminded you of me, because I don't have violent convulsive gestures. Well, let's come on to something that is reminiscent of you, and that is Dominic. his incredible intellectual brilliance.
有一只眼睛失明了，而且基本上，无论你什么时候在后来遇到约翰逊博士，我的意思是，你一眼就能看出来。比如，他患有淋巴结核，他在抽搐，他在做各种各样的动作。比如，从外表上看，他是一个非常让人难以生出好感的人，对吧？是的。他有剧烈、抽搐般的动作，很多人会觉得这令人担忧。这就是为什么当我听到你说约翰逊博士身上有让我想起你的元素时，我会挑起眉毛，因为我没有剧烈抽搐的动作。好吧，让我们谈谈一件确实让你想起你的事，多米尼克。那就是他令人难以置信的才华。
What do you want? I don't want anything. There's an agenda here undoubtedly. Like there's some of this is, they're gearing up for something. I find this sinister and unsettling. I'm just an incredibly nice person. And when there are compliments to be paid, I'm happy to pay them. Okay, go for it.
你想干什么？我什么都不想干。这背后无疑是有企图的。比如其中一些是，他们在为什么做铺垫。我发现这既阴险又让人不安。我只是一个极其善良的人。当有赞美需要给出时，我很乐意给出。好吧，请继续。
So this little boy is growing up. He's, you know, covered in scars on his face. He's twitching, always bumping into tables and things. And yet it is clear the moment he goes to school, you know, this guy is incredible. So his nursery teacher, who Johnson adored, she described him as the best scholar I ever had. And Johnson was always telling this to Paul Swell. He's very, very proud of it. And then he goes to grammar school and he masters Latin and Greek, and particularly Latin, to an incredibly proficient degree.
所以这个小男孩正在长大。他，你知道的，脸上有疤痕。他在抽搐，总是撞到桌子和其他东西。然而，从他上学的那一刻起就很清楚，这家伙太不可思议了。所以他的幼儿园老师——约翰逊非常崇拜她——把她描述为“我教过的最好的学生”。约翰逊总是把这件事告诉博斯韦尔。他对此感到非常非常骄傲。然后他上了文法学校，精通了拉丁语和希腊语，尤其是拉丁语，达到了令人难以置信的精通程度。
He'll be one of Britain's great Latinists. And so basically, the young Johnson will read anything, although interestingly, not all the way through. He was always very contemptuous of people who read books all the way through. He's an expert at gutting a book. Gutting a book. Exactly. Again, quite sound brookian. I will say he'd be very good on a podcast, although the convulsive motions would be
他将成为英国伟大的拉丁语学者之一。因此，基本上，年轻的约翰逊会阅读任何东西，尽管有趣的是，并不是从头读到尾。他一向非常鄙视那些把书从头读到尾的人。他是“剖析一本书”的专家。剖析一本书。没错。同样，这非常符合布鲁克式的作风。我得说他在播客里会表现得很出色，尽管那些抽搐的动作会让人
disturbing. Well, it would add drama to the video, I guess. And also he has an amazing memory. So all he has to do, it seems, is read a page from a book and he can recall it years later. So he's very, very intellectually impressive. However, there are clouds, it has to be said, on the academic horizon. So one of these is a quality that Johnson lamented all his life and was a always trying to deal with. And he saw it as his besetting fault that he was indolent. And what he
感到不安。嗯，我想这会为视频增加一些戏剧性吧。而且他有着惊人的记忆力。所以他只需要读一读书中的一页，多年后他依然能回忆起来。因此，他在智力上非常令人印象深刻。然而，必须承认，学术地平线上也有乌云。其中之一就是约翰逊一生都在哀叹并总是试图克服的一种品质。他认为这是自己挥之不去的缺点，那就是他很懒散。而他
meant by indolent wasn't just kind of, you know, rank laziness, but I think a kind of depression. Yeah. The dejection so profound that he could barely move, let alone kind of open the pages of a book. And periodically this would afflict him. And interestingly, this is why he was a very robust believer in corporal punishment. So to quote him, no severity is cruel, which obstinacy makes necessary for the greatest cruelty would be to desist and leave the scholar too careless for instruction and too much hardened for reproof. You know, this would be an absolutely splendid Daily Mail page 8 article. The way to deal with the mental health crisis is to bring back corporal punishment. That's what Dr. Johnson would have done and he was the greatest Englishman.
所说的懒散不仅仅是某种，你知道的，纯粹的懒惰，而我认为是一种抑郁症。是的。那种深刻的沮丧感，让他几乎无法动弹，更不用说翻开书页了。这种状态会周期性地折磨他。有趣的是，这就是为什么他是一个坚定的体罚信仰者。引用他的话：“没有任何严厉是残酷的，只要固执使之成为必要，因为最大的残酷将是放弃不管，让学者对教导过于粗心，对责备过于顽固。”你知道的，这绝对会是一篇极好的《每日邮报》第八版文章。应对心理健康危机的办法就是恢复体罚。约翰逊博士就是这么做的，而他是最伟大的英国人。
I mean, one of the salient factors of Johnson is that he has no self-pity whatsoever. He does not say, oh, well, it's understandable that I didn't read a book because I was depressed. He says, thank God that I got beaten to make me read the book. and this is very much his approach to life. So that's one problem he has. And the other obvious problem is that his parents have no money. And this is a real problem because he's very qualified to go to university where he could earn the BA that would then open up all kinds of doors to him.
我的意思是，约翰逊的一个显著特点是他完全没有自怜。他不会说：“哦，好吧，我没读书是可以理解的，因为我很沮丧。”他说：“感谢上帝，我挨了打，这逼我读书了。”这非常符合他对生活的态度。所以这是一个问题。另一个显而易见的问题是他父母没有钱。这是一个真正的问题，因为他完全有资格上大学，在那里他可以获得学士学位，从而为他打开各种各样的大门。
But you have to have the money. And he doesn't have the money. And then unexpected, I said how his mother is slightly better connected than his father. And she gets a small legacy. And this is enough not to pay for Johnson to go for the whole of the university course, but for one year. And his father very touchingly matches this legacy by making the only contribution that he could, which is the loan of 100 books. You know, and that's, you know, to remove 100 books from his shop is quite a big deal. And it's,
但你必须有钱。而他没有钱。然后出乎意料的是，我刚才说过他的母亲背景比他的父亲稍微好一点。她得到了一小笔遗产。这笔钱不足以支付约翰逊完成整个大学课程的费用，但足够支付一年的学费。而他的父亲非常感人地通过做出他唯一能做出的贡献来匹配这笔遗产，那就是借出了100本书。你知道的，这，从他的书店里拿走100本书可不是一件小事。而且这，
you know, it's a real investment. And so Johnson goes to Oxford. He's got his books. He's got enough money to last him for a year. And he goes to Pembroke College. And there, it seems to his teachers and his contemporaries that he is forging, you know, a brilliant career for himself. So one of his tutors said later of Johnson that he was the best qualified for the university that he had ever known come there and one of Johnson's fellow students. He was caressed and loved by all about him. This was, I am persuaded, the happiest part of his life. But that was not Johnson's memory of his time at Pembroke. And he said to Boswell years later, our sir, I was rude and violent. It was bitterness, which they mistook for frolic.
你知道的，这是一笔真正的投资。于是约翰逊去了牛津。他带着他的书。他有足够维持一年的钱。他进入了彭布罗克学院。在那里，他的老师和同代人似乎觉得他正在为自己开创一段辉煌的职业生涯。因此，他的一位导师后来这样评价约翰逊：他是他所知道的来到这里的人中最具大学资格的学生。而约翰逊的一位同窗则说：他受到周围所有人的爱戴和呵护。我坚信，这是他一生中最快乐的时光。但那并不是约翰逊对在彭布罗克求学时光的回忆。他多年后对博斯韦尔说：“噢，先生，我是粗鲁而暴烈的。那是痛苦，而他们误以为那是嬉闹。
I was miserably poor and I thought to fight my way by my literature and my wit. And so I disregarded all power and all authority. So like so many students, he was putting a sort of brave face on his private pain and people didn't see it. Yeah. And there's a kind of quality of rebelliousness that Johnson is articulating there that again is a feature of his life, you know, the whole way through. And clearly also he's very sensitive to how poor he is relative to all the other students. And he felt the effects of poverty in various ways. So for instance, he couldn't afford to go home in the holidays.
我穷困潦倒，我以为可以用我的文学和机智来杀出一条血路。因此我无视所有的权力和权威。”因此，就像许多学生一样，他在私人痛苦面前强颜欢笑，而人们并没有看出来。是的。约翰逊在那里表现出某种叛逆的特质，这再次成为他一生的特征，贯穿始终。显然，他对自己在经济上相对于其他所有学生的贫穷也非常敏感。他在各个方面都感受到了贫困的影响。例如，他在假期里负担不起回家的路费。
So he's, you know, after all the other students have gone, he's left kicking his heels in the college. And he's a man who hates being left alone. So he feels very wretched about that. His shoes fall apart. And a fellow undergraduate notices this and buys him a new pair and leave them outside his door. and Johnson is absolutely mortified by this, and he experiences it not as how it was intended a kind of gesture of kindness, but as an insult. And worst of all, of course, as we've said, he can only afford to stay there for one year. And so at the end of that year, he has to leave Oxford and head back to Litchfield.
所以，在其他所有学生都离开后，他一个人留在学院里无所事事。而他是一个讨厌孤独的人。所以他对此感到非常痛苦。他的鞋子破烂不堪。一位同窗注意到了这一点，给他买了一双新鞋，并把鞋留在了他的门外。而约翰逊对此感到非常难堪，他并没有把这当作本意那样的善意之举，而是将其视为一种侮辱。最糟糕的是，正如我们所说，他只能负担得起在那里待上一年的费用。因此在那一年结束时，他不得不离开牛津，返回利奇菲尔德。
And there, it's miserable because his parents are incredibly guilty that they can't pay for him to continue his education. And he is guilty because he knows that, you know, his parents have made this massive. of investment in him, but, you know, he can't get a BA. And so he can't kind of earn the money that he would ideally have wanted to. And so then the question hangs over him, what is he going to do now? And I guess we have, we have listeners who've just left university. And I, you know, that's a pressing issue for many. And Johnson finds himself plunged into such a state of, as he calls it, dejection, gloom and despair, wondering what he's going to do with his life, that one of his friends who wrote years later to Boswell, because Boswell obviously didn't know Johnson at this period,
在那里，生活苦不堪言，因为他的父母为无法支付他继续接受教育的费用而感到无比愧疚。而他也感到愧疚，因为他知道他的父母为他做了如此巨大的投入。投资于他，但他却拿不到文学学士学位。因此他无法赚到他理想中想赚的钱。于是问题悬在了他的头顶：他现在要做什么？我想我们有一些刚刚大学毕业的听众。我知道，这对许多人来说是一个迫在眉睫的问题。约翰逊发现自己陷入了一种他所称的沮丧、阴郁和绝望的状态中，不知道该拿自己的人生怎么办。以至于他的一位朋友多年后写信给博斯韦尔——因为博斯韦尔显然不认识这一时期的约翰逊，
so I was always asking friends the reminiscences. This friend confessed, I was fearful that there was something wrong in his constitution, which might impair his intellects or shorten his life. And Boswell suppressed this. He didn't put it in the biography, because of course, at that time killing yourself was a crime. It's generally thought, isn't it, that Johnson suffered from depression? I think that would be the diagnosis today. It's not a diagnosis, of course, that that Johnson recognizes in himself. He called it his morbid melancholy. Melancholy or, you know, as we've heard he calls it,
所以我总是向朋友询问回忆。这位朋友坦白道：“我担心他的体质有问题，这可能会损害他的智力或缩短他的寿命。”博斯韦尔隐瞒了这一点。他没有把它写进传记里，因为在那个时候，自杀是一种犯罪。人们通常认为，约翰逊患有抑郁症，不是吗？我想这会是今天的诊断。当然，这不是约翰逊自己能意识到的诊断。他称之为他的病态忧郁症。忧郁症，或者正如我们听到的，他称之为
indolence. And I think, so in the five years that follow his return from Oxford, he genuinely felt that he was on the edge of insanity. And again, all his life, he would worry that madness might be lurking. And it's so unexpected in a way because Johnson will become the embodiment of common sense. You know, there's the kind of philosophers who say that nothing is. real. He responds to this by kicking a stone and saying, thus I prove it is real. Now, that's the tamber of the man. He's a man of stolid common sense. And yet all the time he has this shadow,
懒散。而且我认为，在他从牛津返回后的五年里，他真的觉得自己处于发疯的边缘。再次强调，他一生都在担心疯狂可能会潜伏在周围。这在某种程度上是如此出人意料，因为约翰逊将成为常识的化身。你知道的，有些哲学家说一切都不是真的。他对此的回应是踢了一块石头，并说：“我以此证明它是真实的。”这就是这个人的气魄。他是一个充满坚实常识的人。然而，他始终带着这种阴影，
this anxiety, that he might go mad. And so he tries to escape his, let's call it, depression in various ways. So he tries walking to Birmingham and back. And he does this a lot. And he thinks that an invigorating walk will cheer him up. And actually, I think invigorating walks do cheer you up. So I think it wasn't a foolish thing for him to do. And he also takes a range of jobs. So he tries school teaching. He tries tutoring. He tries hack journalism. But again, he doesn't really make a go of any of them. So that's really depressing.
这种可能会发疯的焦虑。因此他试图通过各种方式逃避他的，让我们称之为抑郁症的阴影。所以他尝试步行去伯明翰再走回来。他经常这样做。他认为一次振奋人心的散步会让他高兴起来。实际上，我认为振奋人心的散步确实能让人高兴起来。所以我认为他这样做并不是一件愚蠢的事。他还担任过各种工作。所以他尝试过教书。他尝试过当家庭教师。他尝试过黑客式的新闻工作。但同样，他并没有真正把其中任何一份工作做好。所以这真的很令人沮丧。
He knows that he's brilliant, but he can't seem to make a mark on the world. And then on top of that, there's something that we've already mentioned, which is that he really isn't as prepossessing as he might be. So we have a description of him in his early 20s. He was lean and lank so that his immense structure of bones was hideously striking to the eye. and the scars of the scrofula were deeply visible. And this is obviously a problem for Johnson when it comes to establishing good relations with the ladies.
他知道自己才华横溢，但似乎无法在世界上留下印记。不仅如此，还有一件事我们已经提到过了，那就是他真的不像他可能的那样讨人喜欢。所以我们有他二十岁出头时的描述：他消瘦而修长，以至于他那巨大的骨骼结构在视觉上显得十分骇人，
And Johnson is very, very keen on the ladies. But none of them will give him so much as a second glance. And so, of course, this plunges him even deeper into dejection. But then, when he's 25 years old, lightning strikes, doesn't it? because he meets a woman, perhaps a little older than him, who sees in him a veritable Romeo and Adonis. Yeah, I mean, when you say a little bit, she is a 45-year-old widow. Yeah. But she thinks he's great.
淋巴结核的疤痕清晰可见。这对于约翰逊在与女性建立良好关系方面显然是个问题。而约翰逊非常非常喜欢女性。但没有一个女性肯多看他一眼。因此，这当然使他更深地陷入了沮丧之中。但随后，当他25岁时，闪电击中了他，不是吗？因为他遇到了一位女士，或许比他稍年长一些，但在她眼中，他简直就是罗密欧和阿多尼斯。是的，当你说稍微年长时，她是一个45岁的寡妇。是的。但她觉得他棒极了。
And she says to her daughter, you know, she has a grown-up daughter by this point of Johnson, this is the most sensible man that I ever saw in my life. And she falls madly in love with him. So there's a bit of a kind of macron vibe there, perhaps. And amazingly, on the 9th of July, 1735, in a church in Derby, there is this incredible development. Mr. Samuel Johnson and the widow who has fallen in love with him, Mrs. Elizabeth Porter, become man and wife. Well, what a twist that is. So in the second half, we will discuss Johnson's relationship with his wife, Tettie, as she's called.
她对女儿说，此时她已经有了一个成年的女儿，“约翰逊是我这辈子见过的最懂事的男人。”她疯狂地爱上了他。所以，也许有一种类似马克龙的氛围。令人惊奇的是，在1735年7月9日，德比的一座教堂里，发生了这样一个不可思议的发展。塞缪尔·约翰逊先生和爱上他的寡妇伊丽莎白·波特夫人结为夫妻。真是个神转折。所以在下半场，我们将讨论约翰逊与他的妻子泰蒂（Tettie，人们这样叫她）的关系，
and we will get to some of Johnson's great achievements and we'll discover how he begins to make himself a celebrity. This episode is brought to you by Vanguard. Now, Dominic history is full of examples of people who are promised the world and then got very badly let down. Can you think of a particular example? I can think of a couple of examples, Tom. So we've just been recording a series about the fall of the Inca's
我们将谈到约翰逊的一些伟大成就，并探讨他是如何开始让自己成为一个名人的。本集由先锋领航（Vanguard）为您赞助播出。多米尼克，历史上有太多关于人们被承诺得到全世界，最后却被狠狠辜负的例子。你能想到一个具体的例子吗？我能想到几个例子，汤姆。我们刚刚录制了一系列关于印加帝国灭亡的节目，
and Francisco Pizarro, who was the Spanish conquista or in charge. First of all, he betrayed his business partner Diego dea Magro, and then, shockingly, he betrayed the Inca Emperor Atalpa. Well, Dominic, can I ask you a question? Had Atta Walper been in the hands of Vanguard? Do you think that Vanguard would have let him down? No. The thing about Vanguard, Vanguard was founded on one core principle, and that principle is putting investors first. Tom, for more than 50 years.
以及西班牙征服者弗朗西斯科·皮萨罗。首先，他背叛了他的商业伙伴迭戈·德·阿尔马格罗，然后，令人震惊的是，他又背叛了印加皇帝阿塔瓦尔帕。多米尼克，我想问你一个问题。如果阿塔瓦尔帕掌握在先锋领航手里？你觉得先锋领航会辜负他吗？不会。关于先锋领航，先锋领航的创立基于一个核心原则，那就是将投资者放在首位。汤姆，在过去的50多年里，
Vanguard have been delivering on that promise for millions of clients worldwide. And do you know what's brilliant? you too can open an ICER or a self-invested personal pension and you can choose investments yourself or you can let Vanguard choose and manage them for you. So search a Vanguard investor to find out more when investing your capital is at risk and tax rules apply. Every family tree holds extraordinary stories, especially those of the women who shaped who we are. In honor of International Women's Month, Ancestry invites you to shine a light of and their legacy. Until March 10th, enjoy free access to over 4 billion family history records
先锋领航一直在为全球数百万客户兑现这一承诺。你知道最棒的是什么吗？你也可以开设一个个人储蓄账户（ISA）或个人养老金（SIPP），你可以自己选择投资，或者让先锋领航为你选择和管理。所以搜索先锋领航投资者以了解更多信息。投资有风险，税收规则适用。每个家谱都蕴藏着非凡的故事，尤其是那些塑造了我们的女性。值此国际妇女月之际，Ancestry邀请您去关注她们及其传奇。在3月10日之前，免费访问超过40亿份家庭历史记录，
and discover where they lived, the journeys they took, and the legacy they left behind. Start with just a name or place and let our intuitive tools guide you. Visit Ancestry.ca to start today. No credit card required. Terms apply. Getting ready for a game means being ready for anything, like packing a spare stick. I like to be prepared. That's why I remember 988, Canada's Suicide Crisis Helpline. It's good to know, just in case. Anyone can call or text for free confidential support from a train responder anytime. 9-88 suicide crisis helpline is funded by the government in Canada. Welcome back to The Rest Is History.
了解她们的居住地、经历的旅程以及留下的遗产。只需一个名字或地点即可开始，让我们的直观工具引导您。访问Ancestry.ca立即开始。无需信用卡。条款适用。为比赛做准备意味着万事俱备，比如多带一根球棍。我喜欢有备无患。这就是为什么我谨记988，加拿大的自杀危机热线。了解这一点很好，以防万一。任何人都可以随时致电或发短信，从训练有素的接线员那里获得免费的保密支持。9-88自杀危机热线由加拿大政府资助。欢迎回到《历史其余部分》。
In an astonishing twist, one of the most amazing turnarounds that we've ever discussed on the Rest is history, Samuel Johnson has got married. He's got married to Mrs. Elizabeth Porte, and he calls her tettie, doesn't he? And he, so he likes Tettie for various reasons. She's a sort of jolly and energetic woman. He thinks she's gorgeous. And particularly, he's very impressed by what he calls her bosom of more than ordinary protuberance. Yes.
在一个令人震惊的转折中，这是我们在《历史其余部分》中讨论过的最惊人的逆转之一，塞缪尔·约翰逊结婚了。他娶了伊丽莎白·波特夫人，他叫她泰蒂，对吧？所以他因为各种原因喜欢泰蒂。她是一个开朗且充满活力的女人。他觉得她美极了。特别是，他对她那异乎寻常突出的胸部印象深刻，是的。
And he has a lot of pent-up energy, I think it's fair to say. And is absolutely rapturous that he finds himself married to such a woman. So he, I mean, he remains devoted to her all his life. And also, I think, he feels incredible gratitude. You know, she has allowed him to know what it's like to be loved. She essentially is the person who has rescued him from his morbid melancholy. And also, she has brought some money into his life because, you know, she's inherited from her dead husband, quite a bit of cash. But of course, this only increases the pressure on him to make something of his life.
他有很多积蓄的能量，我觉得这样说很公平。对于自己能娶到这样一个女人，他感到欣喜若狂。所以他，我的意思是，他一生都对她忠心耿耿。而且，我认为，他感到无比感激。你知道，她让他知道了被爱的感觉。她基本上是把他从病态的忧郁中拯救出来的人。而且，她也给他的生活带了一些钱，因为，你知道的，她从死去的丈夫那里继承了不少现金。但当然，这也增加了他做出一番成就的压力。
He doesn't want to end up like his father, who basically, you know, had been leaching off his mother. Johnson doesn't want to do that at all. And so he thinks, well, I've really got to put my shoulder to the wheel. I've really got to make something of myself. And so his first whee's is to invest Tetis in setting up a school. Johnson thinks, you know, I've got a very good education. I'm very smart. That might be something I can do.
他不想落得像他父亲那样的下场，他基本上，你知道的，一直靠吸取他母亲的血过活。约翰逊一点也不想那样。所以他想，好吧，我真的得全力以赴了。我真的得让自己有所作为。因此，他的第一个计策是投资泰蒂开设一所学校。约翰逊心想，你知道的，我受过很好的教育。我很聪明。这可能是我能做的事。
And so he opens it in a small hamlet called Edgel outside Litchfield. And it is clear right from the beginning that it's not really going to be a success. He does not have parents flocking to hand over. their children to him. He doesn't have a degree, but also he has this convulsive twitch. I mean, he looks absolutely bizarre. Come on. You go to an open day at this school. The Blake's got no qualifications and he's jerking around like a madman. I mean, you're not going to say, trust your kids to him. So he does, however, end up with three pupils. And one of these, it's an 18-year-old lad called David Garrick. Oh. Is clearly a very, very impressive student. And Johnson actually becomes
于是他在利奇菲尔德郊外一个叫埃奇尔的小村庄里开了这所学校。从一开始就很清楚，这不会真正成功。并没有家长蜂拥而至地把他们的孩子交给他。他没有学位，而且他有这种抽搐的毛病。我的意思是，他看起来绝对怪异。拜托。你去这所学校的开放日。这家伙没有任何资质，还像个疯子一样抽搐。我的意思是，你不会说把你的孩子托付给他。不过，他最后确实收了三个学生。其中一个是一个18岁的小伙子，名叫大卫·加里克。哦。显然是一个非常非常优秀的 estudante（学生）。约翰逊实际上成为了
comes great friends with Garrick. You know, they're separated by six years, so they're actually almost, you know, contemporaries. I mean, they're closer in age than Johnson and his wife. Completely. So, but despite this, it is obvious that Johnson is not cut out to be a teacher. And as Boswell puts it in his biography, his oddities of manner and uncouth gesticulations could not but be the subject of merriment to them, by which Boswell means his students. And in particular, the young rogues used to listen at the door of his bedchamber and peep through the keyhole that they might turn into ridicule his tumultuous and awkward fondness for Mrs Johnson. So, unsurprisingly, the school folds. And this leaves Johnson even more desperate not to let his beloved Tettie down.
加里克的挚友。你知道，他们相差六岁，所以他们实际上几乎是，你知道的，同代人。我的意思是，他们的年龄比约翰逊和他的妻子更接近。完全是这样。所以，尽管如此，很明显约翰逊并不适合当老师。正如鲍斯韦尔在传记中所写的那样，“他怪异的举止和笨拙的手势必然成为他们嘲笑的主题”，鲍斯韦尔这里指的是他的学生。特别是，这群年轻的流氓常常在他卧室门外偷听，通过钥匙孔窥视，以便嘲笑他对约翰逊夫人的那种狂热而笨拙的喜爱。所以，毫无疑问，学校倒闭了。这让约翰逊更加拼命，不想让亲爱的泰蒂失望。
So his next scheme is to write an exceedingly long and boring tragedy about a sultan and his. his Greek slave girl called Irene. And since Johnson has never seen a play at this point, and he's still only 25, it's not very good. And it doesn't make any money, and he's unable to sell it. And so finally, he settles on the plan that lots of people that we've covered over the course of the rest of his history settle on, which is to leave the provinces and head for London. And Johnson travels there with David Garrick, who is no longer. his pupil, of course, and is now planning to study for the law. And they, uh, they buy a single horse. It's all they can afford. And they take turns riding and walking. Uh, and then they, they arrive in
所以他的下一个计划是写一部极其冗长乏味的悲剧，关于一个苏丹和他的希腊女奴，名叫艾琳。由于约翰逊此时从未看过戏剧，而且他当时才25岁，所以写得不是很好。它没有赚到钱，他也卖不出去。所以最终，他决定采取我们在《历史其余部分》中报道过的许多人都会采取的计划，那就是离开外省，前往伦敦。约翰逊和 David Garrick 一起去了那里，当然他不再是他的学生了，现在正计划学习法律。他们，呃，买了一匹马。这是他们仅能负担得起的。他们轮流骑马和走路。呃，然后他们，他们到达了
London. And from the moment he arrives there, Johnson is absolutely transfixed by the capital, by its scale, by its energy, by its sense of potential. And Johnson is famous to this day as a man who adored London. So 30 years after his arrival, it was still thrilling him, to quote him, the happiness of London is not to be conceived, but by those who have been in it. I will venture to say there is more learning in science within the circumference of 10 miles from where we now sit in London than in all the rest of the kingdom. So he loves it, doesn't he?
伦敦。从他到达的那一刻起，约翰逊就被这座首都彻底迷住了，它的规模、它的活力、它的潜力感。直到今天，约翰逊作为一位热爱伦敦的人而闻名。在他到达30年後，它依然让他兴奋不已，用他的话说，“伦敦的幸福是不可想象的，只有那些身处其中过的人才能体会。我敢说，在伦敦我们现在坐的地方半径10英里之内，其科学方面的学问比王国其余所有地方加起来还要多。”所以他很爱这里，对吧？
I wonder a little bit whether he's quite a spectacle, Samuel Johnson. And maybe in London, there's a slightly less of an issue of people, of him standing out and people staring at him as an odd ball than there would have been a much sleepier, quieter place like Litchfield. But also London offers all kinds of opportunities that frankly just aren't there in a much smaller Midlands town. And crucially, he can make money doing literary things because there are all kinds of opportunities that there were not in the West Midlands.
我有点好奇塞缪尔·约翰逊是否是个相当引人注目的奇观。也许在伦敦，人们对他这个怪人的关注和盯着他看的现象会稍微少一些，不像在利奇菲尔德那样一个较为冷清、安静的地方。但伦敦也提供了各种各样的机会，坦率地说，这些机会在一个小得多的米德兰兹城镇里是不存在的。最重要的是，他可以通过文学活动赚钱，因为这里有各种各样西米德兰兹没有的机会。
Yeah, and you say make money. I mean, he doesn't make that much money, but it's more than he would have done if he'd been kind of kicking his heels in Litchfield. And so he starts doing hack work for a publisher called Edward K. Cave. Cave is very, very enterprising and he's invented what is in effect, I think, the first magazine that we today would recognize as a magazine. It's called The Gentleman's Magazine, and it's just full of all kinds of different stuff. And pretty soon Johnson is writing most of it,
是的，你说的赚钱。我的意思是，他并没有赚那么多钱，但比他在利奇菲尔德无所事事时赚得要多。因此，他开始为一位名叫爱德华·凯夫的出版商做杂务活。凯夫非常非常具有进取精神，他发明了我们今天认为实际上是第一本杂志的东西。它被称为《绅士杂志》，里面塞满了各种各样不同的内容。很快，约翰逊就写了大部分内容，
because he turns out to be brilliant at this kind of thing. And he also does biographies, and he does translations, and he does kind of studies of literature for Cave. And then for Cave, He pioneers a completely new form of journalism, which is to cover debates in Parliament, which his courage of these debates then goes into the Gentleman's Magazine. Now, Johnson doesn't actually attend the debates. In fact, he only ever heard one. Yeah. He's actually very like an ancient historian. He conveys the sense of what he thinks the speeches should have been. So he's basically it's about the vibe rather than accurate transcription. He's basically making up parliamentary debates. He's got a sense of the character of the people who are giving them. He's got a sense of, you know, what they're talking about. But he does this so effectively that essentially anyone who reads these reports assume that they are verbatim transcripts. And the politicians themselves are so flattered by the words that Johnson puts into their mouths that they keep stumb about it. They, you know, they don't reveal that they'd never said any of these speeches. And eventually Johnson comes to feel that, you know, he might be perpetuating a fraud by doing this. And so he says, I would not be accessory.
因为事实证明他在这种事情上非常出色。他还为凯夫写传记、做翻译、做文学研究。然后，他为凯夫开创了一种全新的新闻形式，那就是报道议会辩论，他对这些辩论的报道随后被收录进《绅士杂志》。现在，约翰逊实际上并没有出席辩论。事实上，他只听过一次。是的。他其实非常像一个古代历史学家。他传达了他认为演讲本该是怎样的感觉。所以他基本上是关于氛围而不是准确的记录。他基本上是在编造议会辩论。他有一种对发表辩论的人的性格的感觉。他有一种感觉，你知道，他们在谈论什么。但他做得如此有效，以至于基本上任何阅读这些报道的人都认为它们是逐字记录的。政客们自己也被约翰逊塞进他们嘴里的话奉承得飘飘然，以至于他们对此守口如瓶。他们，你知道的，没有透露他们从来没有发表过这些演讲。最终约翰逊开始觉得，你知道，他这样做可能是在助长一场骗局。所以他说，我绝不当同谋。
to the propagation of falsehood. And so he gives that up. But it's a kind of momentous invention, this idea that you can cover what people are saying in Parliament. And it's something that lives with us to this day. And Johnson is really the founder of that. Now, obviously, Johnson is doing this hat work to make a living. And if you are a writer, probably the most famous thing that Johnson ever said is his great phrase, no man but a blockhead ever wrote except for money. I mean, I do not know a writer who is not familiar with that saying. Inspired by those words. Johnson isn't just writing for money.
去传播虚假信息。于是他放弃了。但这是一种重大的发明，这种你可以报道人们在议会中说的话的想法。这是伴随我们至今的东西。而约翰逊确实是这方面的开创者。现在，很明显，约翰逊做这种杂务活是为了谋生。如果你是一个作家，约翰逊说过最著名的话可能就是他的那句名言：“除了为了钱，没有一个笨蛋会写作。”我的意思是，我不知道有哪个作家对这句话不熟悉。受到这些话的启发。约翰逊不仅仅是为了钱而写作。
Johnson wanted people to read him. In that sense, he wanted admiration. He wanted fame, I suppose. He wanted people to think of him as a great writer. And so one year after he's arrived in London, so that's 1738, he publishes a poem that inevitably is called London. It's about his experiences and thoughts on the capital. And it's a kind of feisty knockabout satire.
约翰逊希望人们阅读他的作品。从这个意义上说，他想要赞美。我想他想要名气。他希望人们认为他是一个伟大的作家。因此，在他到达伦敦一年后，也就是1738年，他发表了一首不可避免地被称为《伦敦》的诗。这是关于他对首都的经历和想法。这是一种充满活力、针锋相对的讽刺。
And it actually makes him a lot of money, more money than his earning for his hackwork for Cave. And it's also a kind of succinct esteem. It's a popular hit, but it's also very, very, it impresses the critics. And it makes a big smash. But it turns out, unfortunately for Johnson to be his space oddity. So Bowie, after he'd released space oddity, it takes him several years before he gets on to Ziggy Star dust. And Johnson, after he's published, London plunges back into obscurity. And by the time he's entered his 30s, he's increasingly feeling that he is a failure, that he is doomed to be a
它实际上为他赚了很多钱，比他为凯夫做杂务活赚的钱还要多。这也是一种简洁的声誉。这是一个受欢迎的热门作品，但也非常非常地给评论家留下了深刻印象。它取得了巨大的轰动。但不幸的是，对于约翰逊来说，这成了他的“太空奇事”（Space Oddity）。所以大卫·鲍伊在发布《太空奇事》后，花了几年时间才推出了“Ziggy Stardust”。而约翰逊在发表了《伦敦》之后，又重新陷入了籍籍无名之中。当他进入30多岁时，他越来越觉得自己是个失败者，注定要在余生中做一个
hack for the rest of his life. He's comparing himself with his mate, isn't he? So he'd gone to London with David Garrick, his former pupil. But Garrick has given up the law by this point, and has embarking on arguably the most glittering theatrical career in British, if not Western history, becoming the most celebrated actor of his day, a man who establishes the template for acting in many ways. And Johnson is, he's not a particularly envious or jealous man, is he? No, I would say, I mean, I'd say further than that, that he treats envy as something to be despised and disdained.
杂工。他一直在和他的朋友作比较，不是吗？所以他和他的前学生大卫·加里克一起去了伦敦。但加里克此时已经放弃了法律，并正在开启英国乃至西方历史上可以说是最耀眼的戏剧生涯，成为了他那个时代最著名的演员，一个在许多方面确立了表演模板的人。而约翰逊，他并不是一个特别嫉妒或眼红的人，对吧？不，我想说，我的意思是，我要说得更进一步，他认为嫉妒是一种应该被鄙视和蔑视的东西。
But I think with Garrick, he does succumb to envy. And I think the chief reason for that is that because Garrick is often performing Shakespeare, You know, he becomes the most famous Shakespearean actor of his day, and he becomes associated with Shakespeare. And this for Johnson is agony, because Johnson probably knows more about Shakespeare than anyone in his day. I mean, he's read the plays backwards and he knows all about them. And it pains him, I think, to see Garrick pontificating about it while he is still a nobody. What about Teddy? So where does Teddy fit into all this?
但我想对于加里克，他确实屈服于嫉妒了。我认为这其中的主要原因是因为加里克经常表演莎士比亚的作品。你知道，他成了他那个时代最著名的莎士比亚演员，并与莎士比亚联系在一起。对于约翰逊来说，这简直是痛苦的煎熬，因为约翰逊对莎士比亚的了解可能比他那个时代的任何人都多。我的意思是，他把这些戏剧读得滚瓜烂熟，对它们了如指掌。看着加里克在大放厥词，而自己依然是个无名小卒，这让他感到痛苦，我认为。那泰蒂呢？泰蒂在这其中扮演什么角色？
Because let's be honest, Teddy flipping hates London, doesn't she? She's gutted that they've moved to London. Yeah, she's got all her friends back in the Midlands. She's really missing them. London's awful, she thinks. It's kind of crowded and noisy and smelly. And so poor old Johnson is feeling very guilty about this. He needs to be in London because partly because he likes it,
因为说实话，泰蒂极其讨厌伦敦，不是吗？他们搬到伦敦，她心碎了。是的，她所有的朋友都在米德兰兹。她真的很想念他们。她觉得伦敦太糟糕了。这里又拥挤、又吵闹、又难闻。所以可怜的约翰逊对此感到非常内疚。他需要留在伦敦，部分是因为他喜欢这里，
partly because it enables him to make money. And so he assuages his guilt by finding tettie quarters that are either on the margins of London or just outside it. And all the money that he's earning essentially is going towards paying for for the rent on these quarters where Teddy stays. But he, of course, has to stay in London, in the centre of the city. And so he has almost nothing left for himself. And in his poem, London, he had written this line,
部分是因为这能让他赚钱。因此，他通过为泰蒂寻找位于伦敦边缘或郊外的住所来抚平自己的内疚。他赚的所有钱基本上都用来支付泰蒂居住的这些住所的租金了。但当然，他必须留在伦敦市中心。所以他留给自己几乎一无所有。在他的诗作《伦敦》中，他曾写下这样一行诗：
slow rises worth by poverty depressed. You know, he knew what he was speaking about. And all the years of his hack work, he lives in kind of run down, squalid accommodation. He wore shabby, worn out clothes. And in fact, all his life, his clothes would be shabby. And even on one notorious occasion, he finds himself with a friend walking around St. James's square all night for want of a lodging. And the great literary biographer Richard Holmes has written a fabulous book about this stage of Johnson's life and his friendship with this guy he went roaming around St. James's with.
贫困抑止了价值的缓慢上升。你知道，他很清楚自己在谈论什么。在他从事零工的那些年里，他一直住在那种破旧、肮脏的住所里。他穿着破旧、磨损的衣服。事实上，他一生中所有的衣服都是破旧的。甚至在一次臭名昭著的事件中，他和一个朋友因为找不到住处，整晚在圣詹姆斯广场四处游荡。伟大的文学传记作家理查德·霍尔姆斯曾写过一本极好的书，讲述了约翰逊人生的这个阶段，以及他与这个曾一同四处游荡的家伙之间的友谊。
And it's called Dr. Johnson and Mr. Savage. So yeah, this is a good example of how the Johnson-Boswell story is a lovely window onto George and London, isn't it? Because although Johnson loves London, he knows how grim and dark it can be if you're on the kind of the wrong side of their wheel of fortune. So the gin, you know, the sort of scenes from Hogarth's engravings, Gin, the kind of the sewers, the ash pits, the homeless people sleep on, the beggars, the prostitutes, all of that kind of thing. And he, he's not a judgmental person about the sort of down and outs, is he? He doesn't turn his nose up at them. He's a moral person, but not a judgmental person. And because he knows what it is to be poor, because he sees the suffering of prostitutes and beggar children and alcoholics all around him, he never despises them.
这本书叫作《约翰逊博士与萨维奇先生》。所以，是的，这是一个很好的例子，说明了约翰逊与鲍斯韦尔的故事是如何成为了解乔治时期伦敦的一个可爱窗口，不是吗？因为尽管约翰逊热爱伦敦，但他深知如果你落入了命运之轮糟糕的一面，它是多么残酷和黑暗。所以那些杜松子酒，你知道的，荷加斯版画中的场景——杜松子酒、下水道、灰坑、无家可归者睡觉的地方、乞丐、妓女，诸如此类的一切。而且，他对那些走投无路的人并不是一个爱评判的人，对吧？他没有对他们嗤之以鼻。他是一个有道德的人，但不是一个爱评判的人。正因为他知道贫穷是什么滋味，因为他亲眼看到周围妓女、乞丐儿童和酒鬼的苦难，他从不蔑视他们。
And if he does have a copper on him, he will always give it away. And if he has nothing on him, then he will stop and try and offer words of kindness. And I imagine that generally that they were received gratefully. I mean, there's a massive man by now, lumbering, twitching. I mean, he might be slightly frightening for people. But I think people always sense the kind of the kindness in Johnson, which coexists with a kind of gruffness and a fondness for, you know, literary spars and things. And Mrs. Thrail, who later in life became a great friend of Dr. Johnson's, she was the wife of a brewer. He became very close to her.
如果他身上有一枚硬币，他总是会把它送出去；如果他身上什么也没有，他就会停下来，试着说一些安慰的话。我想一般来说这些话都会受到感激。我的意思是，他现在是一个身材魁梧、行动笨拙、身体抽搐的人。我的意思是，对人们来说他可能有点吓人。但我认为人们总能从约翰逊身上感受到那种善良，它与一种粗鲁以及对文学争论等的喜爱并存。Thrail夫人，后来的生活中成了约翰逊博士的好友，她是一位酿酒师的妻子。他与她变得非常亲密。
And she said of Johnson that he loved the poor as I never saw anyone else do. And in doing that, I think that he is being true to morals and political principles that he had held since his childhood. So Johnson, as Boswell will be as well, from his youth is a Tory. And as he saw it, he identified with the poor, not despite being a Tory, but because of it. And this may seem odd to some of our listeners, because I think the Tories today. are seen as the party of the affluent and of free market economics and all of that kind of thing. But the meaning of Tory in Johnson's day was subtly different. And we've said how Johnson was always a natural rebel. And I think that in the mid-18th century, to be a Tory could very easily be framed as a kind of rebellion, do you think? Yeah, totally, because the 18th century is the Whigs century. So the Wigs, we did a bonus episode for members of the,
她评价约翰逊说：“他爱穷人，我从未见过其他人能做到这一点。”在这一点上，我认为他一直忠于他自童年起就坚守的道德和政治原则。因此，约翰逊和后来的鲍斯韦尔一样，从年轻时起就是一名托利党人。在他看来，他认同穷人，不是尽管他是个托利党人，而是正因为他是个托利党人。这在我们的某些听众看来可能会很奇怪，因为我认为今天的托利党被视为富裕阶层和自由市场经济等事物的政党。但在约翰逊的时代，托利党的含义有着微妙的不同。我们说过约翰逊天生就是一个叛逆者。我认为在18世纪中期，作为一个托利党人很容易被塑造成一种叛逆，你不觉得吗？是的，完全如此，因为18世纪是辉格党的世纪。所以辉格党，我们为“历史俱乐部”的会员们做过一个特别节目，
the Restis History Club about the Wigs and the Tories with George Awers, who's written a brilliant book about this, which I call The Rage of Party. His online is Capel Loft. He's a great character. And he wrote this wonderful book about the origins of Wigs and Tories explaining exactly where all this comes from. So the Wigs really dominate British politics in this period. They are cosmopolitan.
关于辉格党和托利党，嘉宾是乔治·奥尔斯，他写了一本关于这方面的精彩著作，书名叫《党派之怒》。他的网名叫卡佩尔·洛夫特。他是一个了不起的人物。他写了这本关于辉格党和托利党起源的精彩著作，准确地解释了这一切的来源。因此，辉格党在这一时期的英国政治中占据绝对主导地位。他们是温和派/兼收并蓄的。
They are the party of financiers. They're party of the commercial classes. The great landowners as well. Yes. So they really dominate politics. So the Tories, and this is very simplistic, the Tories are perhaps a little bit more inward-looking, they are more nostalgic,
他们是金融家的政党。他们是商业阶层的政党。还有伟大的地主们。是的。所以他们在政治上占据了统治地位。因此，托利党人——这有点过于简单化了——托利党人可能稍微更加内向，他们更加怀旧，
they are more hierarchical, they are more paternalistic maybe, they are more suspicious of Europe and more suspicious of change and more suspicious of modernity than the wigs are. And so as Britain is being transformed in the 18th century, by the wheels of kind of, and industry and whatnot. The Tories, who are perhaps a little bit more rural and a bit more
他们可能更加注重等级制度，更加带有温情主义色彩，他们比辉格党人更加怀疑欧洲，更加怀疑变化，也更加怀疑现代性。因此，当英国在18世纪被各种车轮、工业等等改造时，托利党人可能稍微更偏向乡土，稍微更加
backward-looking, they feel kind of endangered that the world of the country squire and of old-fashioned ways and of Merry England and stuff is being lost beneath the rush to embrace cosmopolitan modernity. Yeah, and you can see this in Parliament because in the House of Commons, the Tories in Johnson's Day are absolutely the underdogs. You know, they're never more than, say, a fifth of MPs. And so as you say, you know, as Britain booms, as commercial interests increasingly predominate, the Tories do come to feel like they're an endangered minority. And you said how the Tories are very keen on hierarchy. Johnson, all his life, and despite his own humble background, you know, he's a great enthusiast for hierarchy. So he put it to Boswell. I have great merit in being zealous for subordination and the honours of birth, for I can hardly tell who was my grandfather. He believes in the crown and specifically in the right of the exiled stewards to the crown.
思想落后，他们感到一种危机感，即乡村绅士的世界、旧习俗、快乐的英格兰等等，正在被急于拥抱大都会现代性的热潮所淹没。是的，你可以在议会中看到这一点，因为在下议院中，约翰逊时代的托利党人绝对是弱势群体。你知道，他们的比例从来没有超过议员总数的五分之一左右。所以正如你所说，你知道，随着英国的繁荣，随着商业利益日益占据主导地位，托利党人确实开始觉得自己是一个处于危险中的少数群体。你刚才提到托利党非常热衷于等级制度。约翰逊一生都在这样做，尽管他自己出身卑微，你知道，他是等级制度的狂热崇尚者。正如他对鲍斯韦尔所说：“我在热衷于上下尊卑和门第荣耀方面有巨大的功劳，因为我几乎说不出我的祖父是谁。”他信仰王权，特别是流亡的斯图亚特王朝对王权的权利。
So James II had been exiled, Jacobus in Latin. And so the Jacobites, these are the people who will support Bonnie Prince Charlie. Johnson always has a slight kind of leaning towards them. But simultaneously, he is also a devout and committed member of the established church, the Church of England. So if you're a monarchist and if you're a member of the Church of England, in what possible sense then can you be reckoned a rebel? And I think it's because Johnson saw both these institutions, the Crown and the Church, as essential safeguards for the poor and the vulnerable against what Johnson saw as the predatory greed of the wigs, the willingness of the wigs to sacrifice the poor on the altar of kind of commercial and industrial expansion. I mean, Johnson is a small sea conservative, isn't he? And you could see him as being in that sort of bit of the graph, if you're doing a kind of graph of writers. You know, Jero, Tolkien is not that far away. Maybe even George Orwell isn't that far away. People who like the small and the traditional and the established and the rooted and they're distrustful of people who are who like the latest fashionable concept from continental Europe. Yeah. And there's an echo of Orwell in the fact that one of,
所以詹姆斯二世曾被流亡，拉丁语中叫作雅各布斯（Jacobus）。因此，詹姆斯党人，这些人就是支持英俊王子查理的人。约翰逊总是对他们有一点倾向。但与此同时，他也是英国国教（英国建立的教会）虔诚而坚定的成员。所以，如果你是一个保皇派，如果你是英国国教的成员，那么在什么可能的意义上你才能被认为是一个叛逆者呢？我认为这是因为约翰逊将这两个机构——王权和教会——视为穷人和弱势群体抵御辉格党人掠夺性贪婪的重要保障，辉格党人甘愿为了商业和工业扩张的祭坛而牺牲穷人。我的意思是，约翰逊是一个小写的保守派，对吧？你可以把他看作是在作家图表上的那种位置。你知道，J·R·R·托尔金离这里不远。甚至乔治·奥尔威尔离这里也可能不远。那些喜欢小巧的、传统的、建立起来的、有根基的事物，并且不信任那些喜欢来自欧洲大陆的最新时髦概念的人。是的。奥尔威尔的影子体现在这样一个事实中：
Johnson's favorite words is can't. And can't, I mean, essentially it's the use of kind of modish, fashionable words or sentiments to veil self-interest. And the most famous expression of this appeared in a pamphlet that he wrote years later during the American Revolution. And he asks, how is it that we hear the loudest yelps for liberty among the drivers of... Yeah. In other words, the Americans whom he despises, He sees them as hypocritical. You know, their progressive sentiments are merely the veil for naked, greedy self-interest. Hey, he's not wrong.
约翰逊最喜欢的词之一是“cant”（伪善之言）。“cant”，我的意思是，本质上就是使用那种时髦的、赶潮流的词汇或情感来掩饰自私。其中最著名的表达出现在他几年后在独立战争期间写的一本小册子里。他问道：“为什么我们在……的驱使者当中听到了最响亮的争取自由的呐喊？”是的。换句话说，他鄙视的那些美国人，他认为他们是虚伪的。你知道，他们的进步情感只不过是赤裸裸、贪婪的自私自利的遮羞布。嘿，他没有错。
I mean, that explains his take on the American Revolution. He's very hostile to it. But long before the American Revolution, he has, he's already begun making a name for himself. And it's not just as a, you know, for his kind of take on politics, but also as a moralist. By the 1740s, he's starting to, well, it's not exactly famous, but he's starting to be, read by people who find him a source of comfort and who find in him qualities that seem to his readers very attractive. So, you know, his deep sympathy for the underdog, be it the poor on the streets of London
我的意思是，这解释了他对美国独立的态度。他对此非常敌视。但在美国独立战争很久之前，他就已经开始崭露头角了。不仅是因为他在政治上的观点，还因为他是一个道德家。到了18世纪40年代，他开始——好吧，虽说不上确切出名，但他开始被那些将他视为慰藉之源并从他身上发现对读者极具吸引力的品质的人阅读。所以，你知道，他对弱势群体的深切同情，无论是伦敦街头的穷人
or slaves in the Caribbean and America, or even Native Americans whose land is being stolen by British and French colonialists in the wilds of Canada. His kind of matching contempt for hypocrisy and by extension his insistence on what is practical, his impatience with theory, his feeling that kind of academic language, if you like, often expresses a form of oppression. And also, even as he has this sympathy for the underdog,
还是加勒比地区和美洲的奴隶，甚至是加拿大荒野中土地被英国和法国殖民者掠夺的美洲原住民。他对伪善抱有的同样蔑视，以及由此延伸出的对实用之物的坚持，他对理论的不耐烦，他那种认为学术语言往往表达了一种压迫形式的感觉。而且，尽管他对弱势群体抱有这种同情，
he also likes a punch-up. He has a relish for a fight. He talks for victory. as Boswell would one day put it. And in his writings, he does the same. All of that is so George Orwell, isn't it? Or somebody like that of that tradition, or John Kerry, or John Gray. There's a Johnsonian tradition that runs right through British intellectual culture, the kind of anti-intellectual intellectual, who speaks for the common man, who speaks for common sense, who is impatient with kind of camp and jargon and, dare I say, political correctness.
他也喜欢激烈的争论。他酷爱争斗。正如鲍斯韦尔有一天所说的那样，他“为胜利而辩论”。在他的著作中，他也是这样做的。所有这些都太像乔治·奥尔威尔了，不是吗？或者是那个传统中的某个人，比如约翰·凯里或约翰·格雷。英国知识分子文化中一直流传着一种约翰逊式的传统，即那种反知识分子的知识分子，他为普通人代言，为常识代言，对虚伪、行话以及——我敢说——政治正确感到不耐烦。
Johnson would have hated all that. Oh, absolutely. He really would. But you say, he's anti-intellectual. I mean, he's really not anti-intellectual. Of course, he's an intellectual, but he veils his intellectualism in the language of pragmatism and earthiness and common sense and ordinariness. I think that's absolutely true. But even as he's doing that, he is unapologetic in thinking that the things that interest him, Shakespeare or whatever, that there's no reason why people, you know, shouldn't read what he has to say about them. Of course, exactly. Yeah. And so again, through the 1740s, into the 1750s, it's not just his kind of moral sentiments, but his
约翰逊会讨厌这一切。哦，绝对会。他真的会。但你刚才说他是反知识分子的。我的意思是，他其实并不是反知识分子。当然，他是知识分子，但他用实用主义、接地气、常识和平凡的语言来掩饰他的知识分子身份。我认为这绝对是真的。但即使在这样做的时候，他也毫不掩饰地认为，他感兴趣的事物——莎士比亚或其他什么——没有任何理由让人觉得不应该阅读他对这些事物的看法。当然，完全是这样。是的。所以在18世纪40年代到50年代，不仅是他的道德情感，还有他的
learning that is coming to be admired. There is the sense that here is a man who knows almost everything there is to know, that his judgment on matters of literature or language or whatever is absolutely precise, and that he has an incredible mastery of the English language. and it's this sense that in 1746 brings him the commission for which, I guess, thanks to Blackadder, he's probably best known today. And that is the compilation of a comprehensive English dictionary. And to give a measure of the task that Johnson is taking on when he accepts this commission, in Italy, the task of compiling a comprehensive Italian dictionary had taken an entire academy of scholars 20 years to complete. In France, it had taken an Academy of Scholars 55 years to complete. It took Samuel Johnson, who had six junior assistants working with him.
博学开始受到赞赏。人们感觉到这是一个几乎无所不知的人，他对文学、语言等各方面事物的判断绝对精准，而且他对英语语言有着令人难以置信的掌控力。正是这种感觉在1746年为他带来了那项委托，我想，托“黑爵士”的福，他今天最广为人知的事业也就是这个。那就是编纂一部全面的英语词典。为了衡量约翰逊接受这项委托时所承担任务的规模，在意大利，编纂一部全面的意大利语词典花了一整所学者学院20年的时间才完成；在法国，这花了一所学者学院55年的时间才完成。塞缪尔·约翰逊只用了六个初级助手协助他完成这项工作。
And interestingly, of those six junior assistants, five were Scottish. So, you know, his scotophobia clearly was performative. It takes them nine years. And Johnson was a very robust English patriot, and he did not neglect pointing out how well this reflected on English. scholarship relative to French scholarship. Having said that, he's been a hack writer all his life, and in a sense, the compilation of a dictionary was the ultimate masterpiece of hackwork. And famously in his dictionary, he defined lexicographer, the writer of a dictionary, as a writer of dictionaries, a harmless drudge. But the brilliant thing about the dictionary is that it does
有趣的是，在那六个初级助手里，有五个是苏格兰人。所以，你知道，他对苏格兰人的厌恶显然是做出来的。他们花了九年时间。约翰逊是一个非常坚定的英国爱国者，他也没有忘记指出这如何很好地反映了英国学术界相对于法国学术界的优势。话虽如此，他一辈子都是个写稿匠，从某种意义上说，编纂词典就是写稿匠的终极杰作。众所周知，他在词典中将“lexicographer”（词典编纂者）定义为：“词典的编写者，一个无害的苦工”。但这本词典绝妙的地方在于，它最终出版时，
actually, when it's finally published, serve to emancipate him from drudgery forever. So for decades, he's been working in obscurity, hasn't he? With this. sort of anxiety that he's not really made anything of himself. But now all of that changes. Yeah, and he signals his emergence into what is a kind of blaze of fame with a celebrated letter, probably one of the most famous letters ever written in English literature. So at the start of his project, this compilation of the dictionary, his publisher had found him this incredible patron. Johnson had never had a patron before, but now he has one. And this is, he's a statesman, He's a scholar. He's the supreme arbiter of elegance, writes a series of kind of famous letters advising his son on the correct way to behave. And this is the Earl of Chesterfield. And Johnson is granted an initial audience with the Earl of Chesterfield, just as he's about to start writing his dictionary. He then goes back to Chesterfield's house and he's refused admittance to his lordship by, you know, an array of servants. And so Johnson just gives up going to Chesterfield. And basically he forgets all of
确实使他永远摆脱了苦工生涯。几十年来，他一直在默默无闻中劳作，不是吗？怀着一种自己并没有做出什么成就的焦虑。但现在这一切都变了。是的，他以一封著名的信件宣告了自己如日中天的名望的到来，这可能是英国文学史上最著名的信件之一。在这项宏大工程——词典编纂的初期，他的出版商为他找到了一个了不起的赞助人。约翰逊以前从未有过赞助人，但现在他有了一个。这是一个政治家，一个学者，优雅的最高仲裁者，他写了一系列著名的信件，指导他的儿子如何表现正确的举止。这就是切斯特菲尔德伯爵。约翰逊在刚开始写词典时获得了切斯特菲尔德伯爵的初次接见。后来他回到切斯特菲尔德的府邸，却被一群仆人拒之门外，未能见到大人。于是约翰逊就放弃再去见切斯特菲尔德了，
about him. And then the dictionary comes out and Chesterfield writes at a glowing review and basically says, isn't it great? I'm the patron of this. How fantastic. And Johnson completely loses his patience at this and feels that Chesterfield is trying to kind of step in and claim credit where credit is not due. And he writes him this letter. And Chesterfield, to give him credit, is so impressed by it that he actually kind of leaves it lying around in his salon so that people can read it. And so the news of it gets out and people find it very funny. So this is the letter. Seven years, my lord, have now passed since I waited in your outward rooms or was repulsed from your door, during which time I have been pushing on my work through difficulties, of which it is useless to complain and
基本上把他忘得精光。后来词典出版了，切斯特菲尔德写了一篇热情洋溢的评论，基本上说：“难道不是很棒吗？我是这本词典的赞助人，多么了不起啊。”约翰逊对此彻底失去了耐心，觉得切斯特菲尔德试图介入并领功，而这个功劳他根本不配。于是他给切斯特菲尔德写了这封信。切斯特菲尔德不论如何，对这封信印象深刻，以至于他居然把它随手放在自己的沙龙里让大家阅读。因此这封信的消息传了出去，人们觉得非常有趣。这就是那封信：“阁下，自我恭候在您的外室之外或被从您的门前驱逐，至今已经过去七年了。在这期间，我在重重困难中推进我的工作，对此抱怨是无益的，
have brought it at last to the verge of publication without one act of assistance, one word of encouragement, or one smile of favour. Is not a patron, my lord? One who looks with unconcern on a man struggling for life in the water, and when he has reached ground, encumbers him with help. And I think it's fame among writers is precisely because it's something that so many writers have recognized it perhaps in their own careers. So the dictionary really turns Johnson into a star, doesn't it? And then he pours out a series of works that make him equally well-known, because he basically capitalizes on his celebrities.
并且最终将其带到了出版的边缘，没有得到过一次援助、一句鼓励或一丝赞许的微笑。难道一个赞助人，阁下，不就是一个冷眼看着一个人在水中挣扎求生，而当他爬上岸时却用援助去拖累他的人吗？”我想它在作家中间之所以享有盛名，恰恰是因为许多作家在他们自己的职业生涯中或许都对此深有同感。所以这本词典确实把约翰逊变成了一颗明星，对吧？随后他倾注心血创作了一系列作品，使他同样名声大噪，因为他基本上利用了自己的名人效应。
talk us through these? Well, so there's a poem that we've quoted from in our series on Peter the Great. It's called The Vanity of Human Wishes, and it featured Charles the 12th. So people who want to hear that, go back and listen to our series on Peter the Great. He does biographies. He does a massive study of Shakespeare's plays. And he even gets his terrible tragedy, Ireneon, and that's courtesy of Garrick, who by this point has his own theatre. It's not a great critical success, but it does make him a bit of money. And that's important because despite his fame, Johnson is still incredibly poor. He's not making that much cash, I guess, and also he does have this tendency to just give it away to beggars and so on. And actually, in 1758, he gets
跟我们聊聊这些作品吧？好的，有一首我们在彼得大帝系列节目中引用过的诗，叫作《人类愿望的虚幻》，其中描写了查理十二世。所以想听的人可以回去听听我们关于彼得大帝的系列节目。他还写传记，对莎士比亚的戏剧进行了大规模的研究。他甚至把他的那部糟糕的悲剧《伊琳娜》搬上了舞台，这多亏了加里克，此时加里克已经拥有了自己的剧院。它并没有获得巨大的评论界成功，但确实为他赚了一点钱。这很重要，因为尽管约翰逊声名大噪，但他仍然穷得惊人。我想他赚不到多少现金，而且他也有把钱随手送给乞丐等人的倾向。事实上，在1758年，他因为债务被捕，
arrested for debt. And he has to be bailed out by Samuel Richardson, the famous novelist, the author of Clarissa. And then a year later, his mother dies. And he's so short of money to pay for her funeral, that he hurriedly writes this novella, which is called Rasselas. You can still read it to this day. It's actually great. I mean, it's pleasantly short. It has to be said. And it's the story of a prince who he grows up in this kind of sheltered paradise, the paradise of Abyssinia. And then he leaves it to search for the key to happiness and he never finds it. And you can see, you know, Johnson is clearly kind of working issues through there. And it's a great publishing sensation. And again, it gives Johnson a bit of money. But again, it kind of all drives. away. And finally, what does serve to set Johnson on a kind of secure financial footing is that in 1762, he is given a pension of £300. And this comes from the crown, and it is an expression of the state's regard to Johnson for his creation of the dictionary. And Johnson hesitates whether to take it. And one of the reasons for that is that it's coming from George III, who is from the House of Hanover, so not from the House of Stuart,
不得不由著名小说家、《克拉丽莎》的作者塞缪尔·理查森出资保释。一年后，他的母亲去世了。他连支付葬礼费用的钱都凑不齐，于是匆忙写了这篇名为《拉斯拉斯》的中篇小说。直到今天你依然可以读到它。它其实很棒。我的意思是，不得不说它篇幅短小精悍。这是一个王子的故事，他在一个受庇护的天堂里长大——阿比尼西亚的天堂。然后他离开那里去寻找幸福的钥匙，却始终没有找到。你可以看出，约翰逊显然是在其中探讨一些人生问题。这是一部轰动的出版物。它再次为约翰逊赚到了一点钱。但同样，这些钱很快又被花光了。最后，真正让约翰逊走上稳固财务基础的是，在1762年，他获得了一笔300英镑的年金。这笔钱来自王室，是对约翰逊编纂词典这一成就的国家表彰。约翰逊对是否接受它犹豫不决。其中一个原因是这笔钱来自属于汉诺威王朝的乔治三世，而不是斯图亚特王朝，
and Johnson is still affecting his loyalty to the Stuarts. And also there's a famous definition of pension in his dictionary. In England, it is generally understood to mean pay given to a state hireling for treason to his country. So you could say there's an element of hypocrisy in him taking the pension, but the Prime Minister, the Earl of Butte, says to him, this is not for anything you are to do, but for what you have done. So basically, there's no strings attached. This is just a recognition for your achievements.
而约翰逊当时仍在装模作样地保持对斯图亚特王朝的忠诚。此外，他的词典中对“年金”有一个著名的定义：“在英国，它通常被理解为支付给国家雇佣文人以换取其背叛国家的报酬。”所以你可以说他接受年金带有某种虚伪的成分，但首相伯爵布特对他说：“这不是为了你要做的事，而是为了你已经做过的事。”所以基本上，没有任何附加条件。这只是对你成就的认可。
Don't worry. There's no political subtext here. And Johnson takes it. And this transforms his finances. It does. And from that point on, he always defends his taking of the pension in very robust terms. So that's a great help. But throughout this period, even as he is starting to become a celebrity, he remains
别担心，这里没有什么政治潜台词。于是约翰逊接受了。这彻底改变了他的财务状况。确实如此。从那时起，他一直以非常强硬的言辞为自己接受年金进行辩护。所以这真是一个巨大的帮助。但在整个这段时期里，尽管他开始成为一个名人，他依然
beset by, you know, his indolence, his dejection, his feelings of depression. And I think that this is bred of a besetting sense of loneliness. So Tettie, his beloved wife, had died in 1752. And that means that Johnson is, you know, he's now living without a female companion. And I think he feels the lack of female companionship very deeply. He, you know, he remains a creature of flesh and blood. But he's not the kind of man, as we will discover Boswell is, who will go out and pay. Johnson is also a man of the utmost moral probity.
受困于，你知道的，他的懒惰、沮丧和消沉的情绪。我认为这是由一种挥之不去的孤独感孕育而成的。泰蒂，他深爱的妻子，在1752年去世了。这意味着约翰逊现在，你知道的，他过着没有女性伴侣的生活。我想他深深地感到了缺乏女性陪伴。他，你知道的，他依然是一个有血有肉的人。但他不是那种人，正如我们将发现的鲍斯韦尔那样，会出去花钱。约翰逊也是一个具有极高道德正直的人。
And there's a wonderful story that's in Bosworth's biography of how during the rehearsals for Rairini, so at Garrick's theatre, Johnson writes to Garrick, I'll come no more behind your scenes, David, for the silk stockings and white bosoms of your actresses excite my amorous propensities. Yeah, he can't trust himself. No, he can't trust himself. And so he doesn't have a wife, and so he becomes ever more dependent on his friends to keep his melancholy. Collie at Bay. And he's always been a sociable man, but now he becomes sociable in a kind of almost relentless way, I think.
鲍斯韦尔的传记里有一个精彩的故事，讲的是在排练《伊雷妮》期间，也就是在加里克剧院，约翰逊写信给加里克：“大卫，我再也不去你的后台了，因为你女演员们的丝袜和白皙胸脯激起了我的好色倾向。”是的，他信不过自己。不，他信不过自己。因此他没有妻子，所以他越来越依赖朋友来驱散他的忧郁。他一直是个善于社交的人，但现在他变得几乎以一种坚持不懈的方式去社交。
If there aren't people to talk to, he misses their company terribly. And he sort of hangs around. So people will come and see him in his rooms. So he has an apartment in the Intert Temple Lane. He'll hang out on the Fleet Street in his favorite pub, which is called the Maiter. He'll hang out at the shops at Covent Garden. And so it is. then on 16th of May 1763 he meets one fan in particular, a Johnson superfan, the man who is going to ensure his immortality.
如果没有人可以交谈，他会无比怀念他们的陪伴。他总是闲晃。所以人们会来他在内殿巷的房间看望他。他会在弗利特街他最喜欢的名为“米特”的酒吧闲逛。他会在科芬园的商店闲逛。就这样，在1763年5月16日，他遇到了一个特别的粉丝，一个约翰逊超级粉丝，这个将确保他流芳百世的人。
Yeah, and that fan, of course, was the 22-year-old James Boswell, and he will be the subject of our next episode. And just a warning, unlike in this episode, there will be quite a lot of bad behavior. All right. So that episode will be out on Thursday. Now, there will be a lot of people, I imagine, who are thinking about the social social, of which Johnson was a part with Garrick and Boswell and all these great characters will reflect on how lovely it is to be part of a social circle themselves, a club modeled after Dr. Johnson's own club, and that is, of course, The Rest is History Club, which is probably the only club in
是的，那个粉丝，当然就是22岁的詹姆斯·鲍斯韦尔，他将成为我们下一集的主题。顺便警告一下，与这一集不同，下一集会有相当多的不良行为。好的。那一集将在周四播出。现在，我想会有很多人在想，约翰逊与加里克、鲍斯韦尔以及所有这些伟大人物所在的社交圈，会反思身处一个社交圈是多么美好，一个仿照约翰逊博士自己的俱乐部建立的俱乐部，那当然就是“历史的其余部分”俱乐部，这可能是
human history that dazzles more brightly than the clubs of the 18th century. And members of the Restis History Club can hear the whole of this series about Johnson and Boswell right now. And if you want to join them and be part of our chat community, as Dr. Johnson will have called it, then you just head to the rest is history.com. And on that bombshell, Tom, thank you very much. And goodbye, everybody. Goodbye. Hi, everybody.
人类历史上比18th世纪的俱乐部还要耀眼的俱乐部。“历史的其余部分”俱乐部的成员现在就可以听到关于约翰逊和鲍斯韦尔这一系列的全部内容。如果你想加入他们并成为我们聊天社区的一员，用约翰逊博士的话来说，那么你只需前往therestisistory.com。带着这个重磅消息，汤姆，非常感谢你。大家再见。再见。大家好。
We have a very exciting merchandise update to share with you all. We do indeed, Dominic. So we have come back to you with another exclusive Rest is History T-shirt. And I say exclusive because it is only for me. members. So Graham Johnson, who is one of our beloved Athelstands, has come up with an absolutely stunning illustration. So this time, it is an absolutely beautiful scene that he has created to commemorate the journey of Samuel Johnson and James Boswell. So the scene on the t-shirt is kind of modelled in the style of a 1930s railway advert in Britain and it shows Johnson and Boswell on their
我们有一个非常令人兴奋的周边更新要与大家分享。的确如此，多米尼克。所以我们带着另一款独家的“历史的其余部分”T恤回到了大家身边。我说独家是因为它只为我们的会员准备。所以格雷姆·约翰逊，我们深爱着的阿特尔斯坦人之一，想出了一幅绝对惊艳的插图。所以这一次，这是一个绝对美丽的场景，他创作这个场景是为了纪念塞缪尔·约翰逊和詹姆斯·鲍斯韦尔的旅程。所以T恤上的场景有点模仿英国1930年代铁路广告的风格，它展示了约翰逊和鲍斯韦尔在他们的
tour of the Highlands and Hebrides. And Boswell is sat there taking notes. And a large, I think it's fair to say, Dr. Johnson is riding off into the mountains while his horse buckles slightly under his weight. It truly is a wonderful t-shirt. I love it so much that under my hoodie, I'm actually wearing three of them right now
高地和赫布里底群岛之旅。鲍斯韦尔坐在那里做笔记。我认为可以公正地说，约翰逊博士体型庞大，正骑着马冲向群岛，而他的马在他的体重下微微有些支撑不住。这真是一件极好的T恤。我太喜欢它了，在我的连帽衫下面，我其实正穿着其中的三件
because I like them so much. And if you want to get your hands on one of these lovely t-shirts, what you need to do? Well, you need to head to the new The Restis History website. log in and head to the members section and there you'll be able to get your hands on one of these delightful garments. And if you're an Apple member,
因为我太喜欢它们了。如果你想买到这些可爱的T恤之一，你需要做什么？嗯，你需要前往全新的“历史的其余部分”网站。登录并前往会员专区，在那里你将能够买到这些令人喜爱的服装。如果你是苹果会员，
then you'll need to join our members mailing list to get access. So to do that, just send an email to the rest is history at goalhanger.com with Apple member in the subject line and a screenshot of your membership and you will then be sent the link.
那么你需要加入我们的会员邮件列表才能获得访问权限。为此，只需发送一封电子邮件至therestisistory@goalhanger.com，主题行写上“苹果会员”并附上你的会员资格截图，然后你就会收到链接。
Now, there'll be some people watching this who are not yet members of the show. And this surely is the spur that you need to get involved. So if you join the show, not only you will be able to get your hands on this tremendous merchandise, you will also get early access to all our series. So you'll be listening before the Hoypiloi. You will get exclusive members content. So the exclusive mini series that are rolling out this year.
现在，会有一些看这个节目的人还不是节目的会员。这绝对是你需要参与的动力。因此，如果你加入这个节目，你不仅能够买到这些极棒的周边，你还将获得我们所有系列的抢先收听权限。所以你将在平民百姓之前收听。你将获得独家会员内容。也就是今年推出的独家迷你剧。
You'll get bonus episodes. You'll get all kinds of unbelievable benefits. So many benefits that I can't even begin to. to list them now. There's literally never been a better time to join up. So just go to the rest is history.com and you know what you've got to do. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你将获得奖励剧集。你将获得各种令人难以置信的福利。福利太多了，我甚至现在都无法一一列举。真的从来没有比现在更好的加入时机了。所以只需前往therestisistory.com，你知道你该怎么做。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。